Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Soll dir schöne Grüße ausrichten.
Ja, schönen Gruß zurück ans Murmeltier.
Logbuch des Politik Nummer 4hundertundvierzig vom ähm was haben wir denn heute?
24.9., du sagst es zwanzig22 oder für die Freunde der besonderen Zahlen äh Prägnanz zwei,
tausendzweiundzwanzig. Ja und das Murmeltier grüßt.
Das Murmeltier schöne Grüße vom Murmeltier an Nancy Fäser.
Ja, ja. Die Dinge kommen immer wieder. Äh das ist auch schon wirklich, das ist schon irgendwie finde ich schon so wieder so ein Meme in sich und auch ein Meme in dieser Sendung in gewisser Hinsicht, ne, dass wir dann also wirklich seit wir diese Sendung machen, seit.
War das ja schon durch das Thema.
Immer wieder dieselbe Geschichte guckt. Aber dazu kommen wir dann gleich.
Das ist das einer unserer Bestseller.
Manchmal wünscht sich auch irgendwie wir könnten das mal mit irgendeinem anderen Thema kannibalisieren irgendwie neu. Wir müssen neue Produkte entwickeln.
Ja. Könnte sich nicht mal was Neues einfallen lassen.
Ja, vielleicht müssen wir uns was Neues einfallen lassen.
Ich habe das schon getwittert, ne, weil ähm Marina Weißband nee Quatsch äh,
Doch war das ich weiß gar nicht. Irgendjemand hatte dazu getwittert mhm ähm Theresa Bücker war das genau. Das ist irgendwie, ne, immer wieder der gleiche Mist seit 15 Jahren, ne und ähm tatsächlich ist das so,
ähm meine Oma, ja, die äh hatte irgendwann, die war irgendwann dement.
Und äh wenn ihr dann so Fernsehen schaute, dann hat die immer äh gesagt, det kam doch gestern schon. Ja und der also bei Tagesschau, ne, wo wo du dir sicher bist, das kam gestern nicht so, ne?
Und ich habe damals darüber gelacht mehr, aber heute sitze ich hier und denke mir, ich werde auch irgendwie jetzt jetzt kommt es, dass er sofort seine Schwächung hä, das haben die doch schon verboten.
Haben wir doch schon.
Wem netzpolitisches Alzheimer? Also.
Der weiß gar nicht mehr, der ist dement, der weiß gar nicht mehr, wie oft die Vorratsdatenschwangerung schon verboten wurde. Der kann mir gar nicht mehr zählen.
Na ja, aber du weißt doch, seitdem ich Alzheimer habe, lerne ich jeden Tag neue Freunde kennen.
Ja, das äh.
Auch was für sich.
Ehrlich gesagt keine so lustige Krankheit, aber äh soll uns nicht davon abhalten Witze drüber zu machen, denn äh Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem lacht.
So sieht's aus. Wir starten aber mit Feedback. Gab's wieder einiges, weil wir wieder alles falsch gemacht haben oder.
Anleitungen, Anleitungen, wie ich einen Panzer klauen kann.
Genau, wir haben ja wir haben ja darüber gerätselt, weil wir ja eigentlich äh weitgehend inkompetent sind in in diesen Bereichen, wie euch ja äh oft auffällt.
Wer beide nicht gedient.
Ball nicht gedient und haben keine Ahnung, noch nie aufm Panzer. Weiß nicht, warst du schon mal in der Nähe eines Panzers?
Also wie weit war ein Panzer schon mal? Nee, ich meine jetzt so Kampfpanzer. So richtig so Leopard. Warst du nicht.
Bestimmt hat mal irgendwo einer hier doch im äh Straße siebzehnten Juni stehen noch zu äh diese russischen Panzer.
Aber jetzt nicht so einer im Betrieb oder so wie so Minister das so machen, ne?
Da ja im Betrieb bei mir im Betrieb gibt's keine Panzer. Ich arbeite noch nicht mal bei Rheinmetall.
Ja, aber siehst du mal, ich auch nicht.
Also einen echten Panzer, ich weil ich glaube, es gibt irgendwo ich habe bestimmt schon mal einen gesehen so, aber äh äh vielleicht im Museum oder so.
Aber mal ehrlich, es ist noch nicht mal so einer an dir vorbeigefahren, du hast dir keinen angeschaut, du warst auch nicht mal auf einem oder so was. Hast du nicht gemacht, geschweige denn drin gesessen.
Also das kann ich sagen, ich habe noch keinen Gefahren. Das bin ich mir sicher und auch ich glaube, ich habe auch nie einen einen tatsächlich einsatzbereiten,
Also einer, der noch gegangen wäre, ja? Wobei, wer weiß, äh äh die da am siebzehnten Juni stehen, vielleicht sind die auch noch völlig in Ordnung,
haben die Russen sich gedacht, komm, zwei lassen wir da stehen. Dann haben wir, war's hast du?
Die Zombie-Panzer vom siebzehnten Juni. Na ja, also wir haben uns ja gefragt oder du hast dich das gefragt, glaube ich, ne oder hast du's vermutet, ob so ein Panzer einen Zündschlüssel hat oder sowas, also wie man den irgendwie, kann man den abschließen, ne?
Dazu kommentiert Freitag. Deutsche Panzer, zum Beispiel Leopard zwei
werden üblicherweise beim längeren Abstellen mit einem herkömmlichen Vorhängeschluss an der Luke über dem Ladeschützenplatz gesichert. Mit einem Klappsparten oder Bolzenschneider kommt man schon recht weit. Weiterhin hat der Fahrer einen Zündschlüssel,
einen Schraubendreher ersetzt werden kann.
Schon mal gut.
Aber das war so die Kategorie, wo ich mir dachte, so ja okay, so also wenn das gesichert ist, dann dann dann müsste ein Schraubenzieher ausreichen, ne? Oder Schraubdreher, wie es hier korrekt formuliert wurde.
Dann äh fügt er noch hinzu, am besten aufhalten, kann man diese ungetüme übrigens in dem die Luftzufuhr des Dieselmotors an den Luftansaughutzen unterbrochen wird, dann erstick
der Motor, beziehungsweise hat deutlich weniger Leistung. Für diesen Fall ist sogar eine eigene Anzeige für den Fahrer vorhanden. Üblicherweise hängen Blätter an den Hutzen.
Wiederherstellung der vollen Luftzufuhr ist die Besatzung gezwungen, die Lupen zu öffnen, auszusteigen. Statt Laub eignen sich auch Mülltüten oder Ähnliches.
Da spricht der Fachmann.
Mhm das äh führt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit, aber wir stellen fest, äh man kann also so Panzer schon irgendwie abschließen, aber das ist jetzt äh,
wie ich schon vermutete, also da da so ein Panzer ja im Zweifelsfall, also wenn du ihn brauchst
ja, dann ist die Kacke meistens schon so ein bisschen am Dampfen und dann solltest du jetzt nicht unbedingt so sein, so ja, nee, wir könnten jetzt grad das Land nicht vertreiben, weil wussten nicht, wo wir den Schlüssel hingelegt.
Paar Schlüssel vergessen.
Das ist super. Oh Mann ey.
Vor ein paar Tagen gebracht irgendwie bei meinem Motorrad, was irgendwie so ein System hat, habe ich irgendwie den Schlüssel irgendwie nicht in die Hosentasche gesteckt, sondern hinten irgendwie in der Box stecken lassen. Losgefahren und dann habe ich das Ding irgendwie auf der Straße verloren.
Das war auch ja, das war grandios. Weil irgendwann sagte mir dann das System so, ja also hast du so seinen Schlüssel? Der ist jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr in dir,
Worauf finde ich Vollidiot natürlich das Ding erstmal abgestellt habe und wenn du erstmal die Seitenstütze rausgesteckt hast, dann brauchst du aber auch den Schlüssel, um das Ding wieder in Betrieb zu nehmen. Das war dann irgendwie besonders blöd, dann irgendwie andere Wege finden musste.
Jetzt sicherst du deinen Roller immer mitm mitm äh.
Wie heißt vorher geschlossen und und und Schraubendreher. Herr Kommissar, das sieht jetzt anders aus als es ist nicht das, was Sie denken.
Gut.
Noch mehr äh Feedback gab's zu ähm seriösen netzpolitischen Thema oder sagen wir mal eher einem gesundheitspolitischen Thema wird das für uns ja ausführlich unterhalten haben. Nicht die Frage, wie denn das so mit diesen E-Rezepten und Online-Apotheken so funktioniert.
Nächste Sendung wieder was. Da kann ich nur jetzt noch nicht erzählen, das kommt erst nächste Sendung. Aber deswegen lest ruhig erst mal Feedback.
Genau, also erstmal gab's hier einen Kommentar von Stan Bert. Er schreibt zum Thema Telemedizin und Online-Rezept. Das Thema,
Telemedizin wurde 2018 vermutlich auf dem Ärztetag beschlossen. Kann ja mal beschreiben, wie eine Verordnung über Teleklinik Xavier bei uns in der Apotheke ankommt. Also Teleklinik Sava, das sind so diese online.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, online Apotheken ist vielleicht gar nicht so die richtige Bezeichnung dafür oder vielleicht doch, auf jeden Fall so,
Online-Webseiten, wo man halt so Sachen bestellen kann und wo dann, was ich erzählt hatte, auch quasi so äh über Ärzte sich Rezepte äh ausstellen lassen kann über bestimmte Produkte.
Schickt uns eine E-Mail an irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse, also wir, ich werd's mal berichtet jetzt sozusagen, genau, uns in der Apotheke, also, er arbeitet offensichtlich,
in der Apotheke. Zahnarzt schickt uns eine E-Mail an irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse, von der sie denken, sie wäre schon die Richtige. Das gut. Dann ruft uns eventuell noch jemand von Sava an und sagt uns darüber Bescheid, dass da ein Rezept auf dem Weg zu
uns ist. In der Mail ist dann ein zeitlich begrenzter Link, der ins Internet verweist ohne Login und Passwort und so weiter. Da kann man sich da an ein Rezeptbild downloaden.
Nur blaue Selbstzahlerrezepte werden über die Telemedizin verschickt,
Muss ich nichts mit der GKV abrechnen. Rosa Rezepte gehen nicht über die Telemedizin. Die müssten dann schon in Papierform zu uns kommen, um das äh über das Abrechnungssystem zur Krankenkasse äh zu schicken,
Beim E-Rezept werden zur Zeit noch 99 Prozent auf weißes Papier ausgedruckt,
Rcode, die NFC-Smartphone-Lösungs-App heißt E-Rezept vor der Thematik,
funktioniert nur mit den Neuen zwo Punkt einser Krankenkassenkarten mit NFC-Chip. Wenn die PIN bei der Krankenkasse aktiviert wurde und die Identität,
von der Krankenkasse bestätigt wurde. Dann wahrscheinlich mit Videoident oder persönlich oder wie auch immer. Meine Frage beim letzten Webinar an die GEMAtik, was denn mit der Übermittlung des E-Rezepts Krankenkassenkartenchip am Kartenterminal ist,
Wurde mit Rechtsgutachten in Arbeit beantwortet. Womit wir bei der Verordnungssperre wären.
Wenn ich das E-Rezept in der Kasse verarbeitet habe, muss ich noch auf die Quittung des Telematik-Fachdienstes warten. Erst dann ist das Rezept als beliefert markiert. Das kann schon mal mehrere Stunden dauern.
Inzwischen habt ihr genügend Zeit, um mit weiteren Kopien dieses Papierausdrucks E-Rezepts in weiterer Apotheken zu gehen und die gleichen Medikamente mehrmals zu bekommen. Nur die erste Apotheke, die die Quittung erhält,
dann das Rezept abgerechnet und die anderen schenken es euch auf eigene Kosten. Oha. Ich empfehle auch die Apothekenumschau vom September, da klebt ein Heft.
Jetzt fährt er noch die Apothekenumschau empfohlen. Und die Bäckerblume und was okay, aber äh sehr äh haben sie also wieder gut gelöst?
Äh auf jeden Fall merkt man hier schon, man muss verschiedene Dinge äh trennen und was ich halt äh berichtet äh hatte, was ich sozusagen aus Erzählungen kannte äh das ist halt, wenn du eben Dinge bestellst, die,
zwar rezeptpflichtig sind, aber letztlich vollständig von dir selber getragen werden, weil sie nicht von der Krankenkasse erstattet werden, dann geht das eben jetzt auch schon online auf diesem Weg. Ist aber nicht im wirklichen Sinne dieses
E-Rezept, über das wir gesprochen haben, was hier als rosa Rezept bezeichnet wird. Weiterer Kommentar,
Von Moritz zum selben Themenkomplex.
Ähm er fängt schön an mit TLDR, Kurzfassung. Der Versand von Medikamenten ist in Deutschland seit 2004 mit Ausnahmen legal. Dafür muss das Papierrezept per Post an die Versandapotheken geschickt werden.
E-Rezept wiederum kann, direkt übermittelt werden. Die von Tim angesprochene Online-Ärztinnen
existieren, losgelöst von den Apotheken. Diese stellen Online-Rezepte mit qualifizierter elektronischer Signatur aus. Aha. Nutzen also, wie ich das verstanden habe, nicht die GEMAtik-Infrastruktur.
Grundsätzlich dürfen seit 2004 Apotheken in Deutschland Apotheken pflichtiger, also zum Beispiel Kopfschmerztabletten,
und verschreibungspflichtiger, also Blutdrucktabletten oder euer Viagra Medikamente versenden. Diese Apotheken müssen dafür nicht nur eine öffentliche Apotheke betreiben,
sondern auch eine Versanderlaubnis erhalten.
Es gibt eine Liste mit allen Apotheken, die eine Erlaubnis zum Versand von Medikamenten besitzen, die gibt es beim Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte.
B fahren online.
Ebenfalls müssen alle Versandapotheken ein EU-einheitliches grünes Sicherheitslogo gut sichtbar auf ihrer Webseite führen. Dabei muss ein Klick auf dieses Logo zum entsprechenden Registereintrag beim B fahren oder den
entsprechenden Behörden in anderen EU-Ländern führen. Sicher,
Ebenfalls dürfen Versandapotheken aus gewisser äh gewissen EU oder EWR Länder nach Deutschland versenden, solange diese nach deutschem Sicherheitsstandard agieren et cetera und so weiter,
Wenn eure Hausärztin euch also ein Rezept für Viagra Ibuprofen, Blutdrucksecker und so weiter geben
müsst ihr das auf jeden Fall per Post an die Versandapotheke schicken. Apotheken dürfen Medikamente erst nach Erhalt des Originalrezepts abgeben, die meisten Versandapotheken,
Morris, Shopapotheke, Medikamente per Klick DE und wie sie nicht alle heißen, bieten dafür einen Freiumschlag, sobald das die das Rezept erhalten und auf Echtheit geprüft haben, versenden diese die Medikamente, damit DHL und Co. Die stationären Apotheken bleiben
komplett außen vor. Bestätigt auch noch mal das, was wir jetzt im Ersten,
hatten, auch stationäre Apotheken, die einen Bodenservice anbieten, geben die Medikamente erst nach Erhalt des Rezept aus, je nach Apotheke kann auch der Bote, die bei der Auslieferung mitnehmen.
E-Rezept verkürzt nur die Wartezeit bis zum Versand der Medikamente. PDF hochladen, Foto mit der Webcam machen oder das anderweitig elektronisch an die Versandapotheke übermitteln und schon können die Medikamente verschickt werden,
kommt dann wie in der Apotheke vor Ort die Klimatik ins Spiel. Äh Tim hat ja auch noch diesen Art Service von Doc Morris ins Spiel gebracht, also,
war's glaube ich egal. Doc Morris bietet gemeinsam mit dem Anbieter Teleclied die normal zugelassene Ärzte beschäftigen, online Arztbesuche an,
Rahmen von diesen Kammern wie von Tim korrekt gesagt nicht nur Krankschreibung sondern auch Rezepte bekommen. Genau das ist das was ich,
zitiert hatte, wenn ich das bei Teleklinik und Sama richtig gesehen habe, stellen diese aber nur diese blauen Privatrezepte aus. Genau, die müssen selber bezahlt werden et cetera, das haben wir eben schon.
An dieser Stelle kommen die stationären Apotheken zum ersten Mal potenzielle Spiel. Teleklinik spricht auf der Webseite davon,
deren Ärztinnen, die Rezepte per qualifizierter elektronischer Signatur signieren und diese dann in normaler Apotheken,
so weiter vermitteln über die Thematik laut Beschreibung ist also außen vor,
Scheint, wenn ich deren Website richtig verstehe, ebenfalls auf elektronische Signaturen zu setzen und die Rezepte entweder an stationäre oder Versandapotheken zu übermitteln. Also deckt sich jetzt auch noch mal mit dem ersten, momentan nochmal ein bisschen genauer äh ausgeführt,
Das ist sozusagen die Ist-Situation und äh derzeit ist also bei dem ganzen Online-Geschäft die GEMAtik noch außen vor weitgehend.
Ja und dann habe ich dann war ja noch und dann hat uns mir hatte noch jemand geschickt, wie viele Krankenkassen es gibt. Ist irgendwie so eine dreistellige niedrige, dreistellige Zahl gewesen, waren mal viel mehr. Ähm,
ehrlich gesagt habe ich dann nochmal so ein bisschen über dieses Ding nachgedacht. Ich glaube eigentlich reicht das, wenn deine wenn dein Rezept.
Ähm also der der,
der Teil, der online ist, ja, dass du das es quasi Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt ist an die Krankenkasse, da gibt's nicht so viele, damit die das sehen können, ja und dann kannst du in den QR-Code,
ruhig offen reinschreiben, musst du gar nicht verschlüsselt sein, damit ist die Apotheke einsehen kann,
Dann muss es nur noch von einer berechtigten Stelle signiert sein und dann könnte sich die ähm Gamatik,
darauf äh ähm beschränken.
Zu sagen okay, dieses Rezept ist eingelöst, ja, dann müsst ihr die Infrastruktur müsste nur,
sagen, okay, es wir wissen, es gibt ein gültiges Rezept mit der Nummer so und so und die Apotheke XY hat uns jetzt gerade mitgeteilt, dass das eingelöst wurde.
Da braucht die Gamatik überhaupt gar kein Kenntnis vom Inhalt des Rezeptes zu haben.
Also weil weil da ja Fragen kamen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ginge nicht, weil's zu viele Apotheken gibt. Aber genau an die muss es ja auch gar nicht verschlüsseln, wenn du einfach den kompletten Inhalt des Rezeptes,
den QR-Code schreibst.
Also es ich verstehe diese Architektur noch nicht mal, die wir haben. Ich verstehe noch nicht mal, was das soll. Weil wenn nämlich die Apotheke dann sagt, pass mal auf, liebe Krankenkasse, während es mir die wir haben das, wir haben ja das Rezept mit der Nummer so und so
eingelöst und du weißt ja auch was drin steht, wir wissen's auch dann sind die sich über ihre Abrechnung einig und dann muss eigentlich die GEMAtik müsste nur noch einen großen Server haben, der sagt das Rezept ist noch gültig oder nicht?
Thema erledigt.
Ja gut, ich meine ein komplettes Rezept in einen QR-Code. Ich weiß nicht, was so das Maximum an Daten ist, was so da noch unterkriegst.
Es gibt keine Begrenzung.
Na ja, aber es gibt so eine praktische Begrenzung. Die werden dann ausgedruck.
Geguckt, wie ein wie eine wie ein Rezept aussieht. Steht drauf, Medikament und wie lang? Das Freitextfeld, was was ein Rezept hat,
Ja, wo du reinschreiben kannst, was du da ausstellen möchtest. Das passt aber fünfmal in QR-Code. Als als Tiff.
Ja, du lachst.
Mit der Unterschrift von der Ärztin.
Na ja, na gut, also,
Egal, wir können jetzt auch glaube ich das Problem jetzt hier nicht abschließend äh äh lösen. Technisch. Es gibt sicherlich noch tausend Anforderungen, die man jetzt hier auch noch mal mitdiskutieren müsste. Gibt uns sicherlich Gelegenheit, irgendwann mal hier mit jemanden zu sprechen.
Wir werden nächste Woche darüber noch mal drüber reden. Du wirst du wirst dich freuen Tim.
Okay, ich würde mich freuen. Ich hoffe auf alle anderen.
Du bist ja voll der Fan hier von Online-Apotheken, aber.
Geht so.
Wie hast du hast du die Lieferung nicht bekommen?
Ja äh nee, also ich ich es man kann Dinge schön bauen, man kann sie nicht schön bauen, das ist nicht schön gebaut. Was auch nicht schön ist.
Murmeltiertag.
Vorwärtsmorpelt hier. Die Vorratsdaten.
Jeder? Kennt das jeder mit dem Murmeltiertag eigentlich.
Nein, Tim, die sind doch alle viel jünger als wir. Die gucken dich an und denken, guck mal, der der zitiert irgendwelche Filme. Die sind mit lebenden Darstellern.
Ja von neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig,
Also äh auch für den Fall jetzt hier komplett zu den konvertierten äh zu predigen, aber äh wenn ihr den Film nicht kennt, was ich für einen.
Ich lade den auch gerade noch.
Gibt's auch auf irgendwie kann man auch für teuer Geld auf auf äh legalen Plattformen erwerben.
Läuft eigentlich auch mal wieder im Fernsehen, aber das guckt ja wahrscheinlich auch keiner mehr. Wie auch immer, nur für den Fall, dass es keiner kennt. Aber ganz ehrlich,
der Film Ground Hawk Day oder eben wie es so schön auf Deutsch übersetzt heißt und täglich grüßt, das murmelt hier sicherlich eine der gelungeneren äh Übersetzungen von amerikanischen Filmen,
Fällt bei mir in die äh in die top Kategorie von Filmen,
ich halt äh ich habe generell so drei Kategorien, Scheißfilme, gute Filme und Filme, die ich,
permanent nicht mir sozusagen auf Repeat anschauen könnte, ohne dass ich mir dabei langweilig werde. Gibt's nicht so viele, aber der gehört definitiv dazu.
Okay, ich also ich habe den damals tatsächlich im Kino geschaut und glaube danach nie wieder.
Grandios. Bill Mary, beste Rolle, einfach hervorragend äh.
Sozusagen dieser Ground-Talk, der ist halt so irgendwie diese diese komische dieser komische Ritus, wo so irgendwie so ein Murmeltier irgendwie,
angeblich aus unserem Loch rausziehen. Ja, es findet in den USA halt statt so und er ist halt so Bill Mary ist halt so ein genervter Fernsehreporter, der darüber berichten soll, überhaupt keinen Bock drauf hat und überhaupt ein Ziel stinkt.
Stiefel ist. So und fährt da irgendwie keinen Bock drauf. Und dann wird da irgendwie mit so einem Fluch belegt und,
immer nachdem dieser Tag abgelaufen ist, fängt der Tag wieder von vorne an. Und er befindet sich sozusagen in so einer Endlosschleife und muss permanent diesen selben Tag wieder durchleben. Und genauso geht's einem wirklich beim Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ja, es ist äh hat er eigentlich noch jemand Bock drauf oder so was, einfach überspringen? Also ich kriege es nicht mehr, ich krieg's nicht mehr, ich krieg's nicht mehr runter, ne? Also runter eher nicht, aber ähm.
Es ist in dem Film, ja, ist ja sozusagen die Frage, wie kommt der da wieder raus? Weil er durchlebt diesen Tag immer wieder und er muss, nein, natürlich darfst du's nicht verraten.
Aber ich sage dir jetzt schon Tim, so lösen wir nicht das Problem mit der.
Wissen wir nicht, das wissen wir nicht. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie das fünfmal durchlebt und ich glaube, in dem Film ist er mehrere hundert Mal dabei, also von daher na ja vielleicht.
Also genau, also es wurde geklagt von der von Space-Set und der deutschen Telekom gegen die WhatsApp-Speicherung.
Was ist schon mal bemerkenswert finde.
Ja, die in Deutschland aber schon längst außer Kraft äh war, weil also es gab boah, ich ich krieg's noch nicht mal mehr hin. Ich müsste das hier an dieser Stelle jetzt hinkriegen. Es gab äh das Gesetz.
Als ich zu einer Zeit.
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil, die gesagt haben, das geht so nicht. Da haben die gesagt, ah okay, alles klar, danke für das Urteil. Wir wir lernen jetzt aus dem Urteil, machen das einfach noch mal. Hat gleich eine Nummer hingeschrieben, haben gedacht, diesmal merkt's keiner.
Und dann äh dann wurde es zwischenzeitlich, genau, die Vorzeitensprechung kam nämlich aufgrund einer,
europäischen Richtlinie, dann war nämlich der dann war nicht das Problem, dass sie sagt, ja, ja, wir müssen wir müssen die Datensprechung umsetzen, weil das ist ja hier.
Europäische Richtlinie, das heißt, wir müssen ein Gesetz zu Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen, sonst nämlich ähm,
kriegen wir hier müssen wir Strafe zahlen, weil wir europäische Richtlinien nicht erfüllen. Tut uns leid, so, ne?
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war aber schon klar, dass diese europäische Richtlinie vor den EuGH geht und dass die fallen würde. Also haben die noch schnell bevor die weggeklagt wird, nochmal,
in Deutschland gemacht, denn inzwischendurch wurde dann diese diese Richtlinie weggeknallt, ja und,
aber natürlich gab's jetzt die ganzen nationalen Umsetzungsgesetze.
Und dann sagen die Länder so, ja gut, äh wir haben das zwar jetzt hier wegen der richtigen gemacht, auch mit der Argumentation der Richtigen, nur weil die Richtlinie jetzt europarechtswidrig ist, heißt das ja nicht, dass wir hier nicht bei uns zu Hause weiter Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung machen können.
So und.
So einen Fall hatten wir jetzt auch in Deutschland, ungefähr jedenfalls dann äh ähm hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
in Deutschland äh gesagt, naja okay, wir haben ja dieses deutsche Telekom, die sagen, das äh wollen sie nicht umsetzen und die haben aktiv dagegen geklagt.
Und haben gesagt ähm steht denn das Unionsrecht in seiner Auslegung äh durch den Gerichtshof.
Solchen nationalen Rechtsvorschriften wie sie jetzt gibt in Deutschland mit der Vorzeitenspeicherung entgegen.
Und also mit anderen Worten, ja können wir denn hier nicht vielleicht trotzdem vor Ortseinschweinkungen machen? Und dann kommt äh die Money-Quote meint, also wirklich meine meine Lieblings äh mein Lieblingszitat aus dieser Pressemitteilung ist. Ähm,
mit seinem Urteil von heute bestätigt der Gerichtshof seine bisherige Rechtssprechung. Was ist einfach,
so mit unserem heutigen Urteil bestätigen wir, was wir schon vorher gesagt haben, äh was ich äh äußerst äh unterhaltsam finde.
Ähm.
Und Sie haben aber natürlich, und das war, das war ja auch das das Gewahrte, weil jetzt ja wieder, es war wieder quasi alle, die die Vorratsdatensprechung wollen, saßen da und dachten sich, ha äh
wenn wir jetzt Vortrag zur Speicherung müssen wir schnell wieder machen, aber müssen wir noch dieses Urteil abwarten. Bis dahin müssen wir noch warten. Bis dahin müssen wir noch warten. Und dann wird uns ja.
Und so werden ja äh so werden ja höchstrichterlichere Urteile immer interpretiert wenn gesagt wird ah Luz, wunderbar, ihr habt hier ein Überwachungsgesetz gemacht, geht leider überhaupt nicht, weil wir haben da so etwas, das nennt sich Verfassung und äh das äh,
tretet ihr mit Füßen,
Dann gehen die ja hin und sagen, ah wunderbar, jetzt kennen wir die Grenzen der Verfassung. Also können wir jetzt ein Gesetz schreiben, was genau an der Grenze der Verfassung ist, damit wir, damit wir äh danke
an das Gericht, danke an das Gericht, dass uns das.
Die Klarstellung, genau.
Mal erläutert. Danke für die Klatschstellung, super,
Jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir genau an die Grenzen des möglichen und des äh Folgen gehen, um um euch noch mal ein Gesetz herzuschreiben. Finden die auch völlig in Ordnung, ne? So so argumentieren die auch, ja? Kannst du dich mit so ähm.
Den Leuten im Innenministerium unterhalten, denen zu sagen, ja nee, das ist ja voll klar, das ist ja und dafür haben wir heute die Gewaltenteilung. Dafür haben wir die Gewaltenteilung, dass wir äh
dass wir versuchen unsere Gewalt auszuüben und regelmäßig eine auf die Mappe bekommen, aber am Ende sicherstellen können, dass wir auf wirklich das Maximale rausgeholt haben, statt irgendetwas halbwegs Sinnvolles,
So, so viel zum jetzt zum einen äh zum zum Eingang. Ähm.
Der Gerichtshof bestätigt, dass das Unionsrecht, in diesem Fall Unionsrechten, Europäische Union, ja, nicht.
Demokratisch oder Christ Sozialunion. Eine allgemein und unterschiedslosen Vorortsdatensprechungen von Verkehrs und Standortdaten entgegensteht.
Auch nochmal wiederholen. Was ist überhaupt Vollzeitspeicherung? Für die jüngeren von euch, die das noch nicht seit 15 Jahren verfolgen. Können,
Weil sie erst seit seit zehn Jahren überwacht werden auf diesem Planeten. Äh.
Ist die, ist die Idee ähm ihr habt jetzt so einen Internetanbieter
und äh die die stellen euch eine Verbindung zum Internet her und die können das, die wissen natürlich ähm zu welchem Zeitpunkt ihr was gemacht habt,
Die wissen ganz genau äh zum Beispiel würde da jetzt stehen, Tim und ich Podcast gerade remote. Das ist eine äh
Audioverbindung, Web RTC oder was das hier wahrscheinlich ist äh von meiner IP-Adresse äh beziehungsweise
ist ja nicht meine. Ich bin ja ich weiß ja, dass sie Vorratsseiten machen wollen, aber ähm wäre theoretisch von meiner IP-Adresse tatsächlich wahrscheinlich direkt zur Anschlussleitung von Tim und dann könnte man sagen, da gibt's eine Verbindung, die ähm,
hat so und so lange bestanden.
Und wenn es jetzt ein Mobilfunk wäre, zum Zeitpunkt der Herstellung der Verbindung hat der Linus sich in der und der Zelle befunden und die und die Zelle können wir sogar mappen auf einen Standort. Ja? Und dann wissen wir im Prinzip jedes Mal, wenn jemand,
was im Internet macht,
Details muss man natürlich dann nochmal betrachten. Ist es jetzt eine ausgehende TCP-Verbindung? Ist es eine beendete was ist mit UDP? Was ist mit? Aber das das interessiert ja. Die wollen einfach nur wissen, wer wann und wo.
Das soll alles gespeichert werden.
Und dann auf richterlichen Beschluss und zwar von allen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und auf richterlichen Beschluss könnte man dann, kann dann eben die Polizei darauf zugreifen und sagen so, wir verdächtigen den Linus Neumann äh Folgendes getan zu haben
wir wollen jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicher auch von dem haben und dann sehen sie,
Äh aus meiner Wohnung grundsätzlich ein riesiger TCP Stream aus dem Land geht,
Um der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu entkommen,
Und äh an anderen Stellen der Erde wieder rauskommt wo ähm wo wo Rechtsstaat äh noch was zählt, ja? Und ich immer aus dem Ausland äh ich bin quasi
äh remigiert, ich bin Reimport, meine meine IP-Pakete sind Remporte.
Und man könnte sich schon fragen, ob du im richtigen Land Steuern zahlst.
IP Steuer.
Ähm.
Ja, aber so äh uns ja nicht nur Internet, sondern es betraf ja früher vor allem auch Telefon und so weiter. Also generell Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist einfach die Idee. Man speichert erstmal alles,
Auf Vorrat, weil man weiß halt nicht, wofür es mal gut sein kann,
Da es dann für alle gespeichert wird, würde das dann sozusagen im Nachgang auch dritte, vierte, fünfte, sechste, siebte Person mit einschließen können.
Ja? Weil die irgendwie mal A hat B angerufen und BAC angerufen und dann hat den nochmal angerufen und so weiter und äh das ist natürlich aus der Perspektive eines ermittelnden Polizisten.
Geheimdienstlers oder wer auch immer da gerade äh Interesse hat, irgendwas rauszufinden, ist das natürlich Schlaraffenland.
Man kann ja nicht genug Daten haben, was der Geier, wofür es mal gut ist, et cetera und deswegen ist ja auch die Polizei,
Gewerkschaften werde auch immer äh sozusagen spricht und ne die entsprechenden Behörden auch immer so latent für,
hätten wir gern,
Weil wir kriegen's ja sonst nicht auf die Kette, auch wenn's immer wieder Beispiele gibt, die wir hier auch über die Jahre immer wieder mal hervorgezogen haben, wo wo Wunder, oh Wunder, auch ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr gut ermittelt werden kann, wenn man's nun mal ordentlich
probiert und die ganze äh Debatte und was ja dann auch früh schon, ist ja auch ein bisschen auch so so ein wenig der,
vielleicht nicht der Urknall, aber so zumindest der der frühen Galaxienbildung in dieser ganzen deutschen netzpolitischen Bewegung, so a Vorrat
et cetera äh weil weil das einfach an die Essenz geht, denn es ist natürlich auch klar, wenn man von allen alles
für immer speichert oder zumindest über einen sehr, sehr, sehr langen Zeitraum, dann sind eben nicht nur Ermittlungen möglich über.
Die typischerweise zitierten schweren Straftaten et cetera
sondern das weckt natürlich dann auch das Interesse, weil dann kann man natürlich alles mögliche
recherchieren. Da kann man rausbekommen, so aha hier interessante neue Partei, die ist aber sehr populär bei den Leuten. Da gucken wir doch mal, was dahinter ist so. Ne, Quellenschutz von äh Journalisten ist natürlich damit auch vorkommen
unmöglich äh das geht in den medizinischen Bereich rein. Also es gibt einfach so viel sensitive Bereiche
die offensichtlich sind. Natürlich gibt es auch sehr viele sensitive Bereiche aus dem klassischen. Ich habe ja nix zu verbergen äh Spektrum weil dann ist ja sozusagen liegt alles offen da
in dem Moment, wo jemand sich Zugriff darauf ähm.
Herbeischaffen kann, wissen wir einfach, dass das dann auch einfach genutzt werden,
wird, wenn es nicht ausreichend bewacht und sanktioniert wird, was halt einfach irgendwann schwierig wird und äh,
Das ist die die die Gefahr und die Befürchtung und das ist ja auch letzten Endes die Grundlage dieses immer wieder bestätigten Urteils, sei es das vom Verfassungsgericht, sei es das vom
EuGH et cetera. Wie immer wieder sagen, Leute
Also ja, wir verstehen ja, worauf ihr hinaus wollt und was euer Problem ist, aber eben nicht mit dieser Methode.
So, das geht einfach nicht. Und dann sind sie aber auch so nett zu sagen so,
Aber na ja, hm, okay, gut, ja, also irgendwo habt ihr ja auch einen Punkt, weil wenn ihr's mal wirklich verdammt Schlimmes passiert, wär's natürlich auch scheiße, wenn man denn jetzt,
auf gar nichts mehr zurückgreifen kann, weil es ist ja dann sozusagen auch ein bisschen wenig und deswegen stellen wir jetzt mal so drei, vier.
Im Gerichtsmanier oder im Verfassungsgerichtsmanier vage formulierte Einschränkungen,
ja die müssten irgendwie dann doch irgendwie erfüllt sein und dann würden wir vielleicht nochmal ein Auge zudrücken,
Aber nur in genau diesen Fällen und das ist dann genau das, was die Politik sich am nächsten Tag in die Pressekonferenz auf Blatt 1 schreibt und sagt so, ja äh vielen Dank für die Klarstellung.
Geht doch. Jetzt wissen wir nicht, wie's geht.
Geht auch. So. Alles möglich. So. Also fangen wir wieder an. Und wahrscheinlich schreiben Sie jetzt wieder dasselbe Gesetz auf,
schließen es wieder und dann geht es wieder zurück zum Murmeltier.
Und ein solches Urteil wurde jetzt heute gefällt und jetzt schauen wir, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal im im Detail an. Also.
Es geht ähm also wir äh gibt Speicherobjekt sollen sein.
Verkehrs- und Standortdaten, also ne, da haben wir jetzt gesagt, Viehpakete, äh Telefonie und so weiter und auch wo, ne, mit Uhrzeit sowieso.
Und.
Jetzt muss die Frau und jetzt ist die Sache, darf man das? Also grundsätzlich ja darf man, aber nicht bei allen ähm allgemein und unterschiedslos. Also du kannst das durch, du kannst durchaus zum Beispiel sagen, so,
Hier ist der Staat und der Stadt sagt dieser Linus Neumann, dem trauen wir nicht. Wir wollen alles, was der macht, gespeichert haben und dann sagt das Unionsrat, ja, kannst du machen,
ne? Und ähm,
wenn du sagst, ich möchte das aber jetzt von allen machen, sagen die nein. Weil da da übertreibst du ja vielleicht ein bisschen. Und jetzt sagen sie, aber du darfst das theoretisch allgemein und unterschiedslos,
wenn eine ernste Bedrohung für die nationale Sicherheit besteht.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist der Unterschied oder was ist eine Bedrohung für die nationale Sicherheit in Abgrenzung zu einer Bedrohung für die öffentliche Sicherheit hin? Das hatte ich dir als Hausaufgabe gegeben.
Also um vielleicht mal hier.
Ist auch Klausurrelevant.
Genau, also,
wir zitieren ja hier quasi aus der aus der Zusammenfassung des des Urteils so und äh das Urteil ist ja eine Antwort an das Bundesverwaltungsgericht, das einfach gesagt hat, stellt ihr das mal bitte klar, wir kommen jetzt hier nie weiter
und äh die Antwort ist, dass das Unionsrecht nationalen Rechtsvorschriften entgegensteht,
die präventiv zur Bekämpfung schwerer Kriminalität und zur Verhütung schwerer Bedrohung der
öffentlichen Sicherheit eine allgemeine und unterschiedslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Verkehrs- und Standortdaten vorsehen. Mit anderen Worten, wenn es in Anführungsstrichen nur um die öffentliche Sicherheit geht, dann äh,
So erste Einschränkung, nationale Sicherheit. Was ist der Unterschied? Öffentliche Sicherheit ist sozusagen unser Rechtssystem in Deutschland.
All seine äh Gesetze, dass das sozusagen hergestellt werden kann, so unsere normalen Rechtsvorfälle, die allein reichen,
nicht, sondern wo es überhaupt erstmal eine Ausnahme gibt, das ist dann eben die,
nationale Sicherheit und die nationale Sicherheit ist sozusagen die Sicherheit unserer Nation, also unsere äußere Sicherheit, Bedrohung von außen, durch,
Böse, böse, böse Staaten. Ja, die uns an die Wäsche wollen. Aber nicht.
Den zeigt dir von uns selbst überwachen. Und um uns vor den Schutz zu schützen dürfen wir uns selbst überwachen. Alle.
Das leuchtet ein.
Das ist, sagen wir mal, die Kategorie von Bedrohung ab der das äh Verfassungsgericht oder in dem Fall der EuGH halt sagt, dann können wir mal drüber nachdenken.
So und ähm.
Das ist der Unterschied, ne. Also öffentliche Sicherheit ist sozusagen unser Rechtssystem, unsere normalen äh Sicherheits äh Bedenken et cetera
Dafür reicht das halt nicht. Also wenn ihr jetzt hier irgendwelche Kiffer fangen willst oder so, nee, dann ist euch was anderes einfallen lassen. Nur deswegen wird jetzt hier nicht mal alles gespeichert.
Muss sich eben schon äh um sowas handeln. Das Problem ist natürlich immer mit diesen Daten, sondern da hatten sie auch Vorrat gespeichert werden sollen. Das heißt, man will ja
R speichern, weil man danach unter Umständen an Interesse daran hat. Man weiß ja vielleicht vorher nicht, ob das jetzt öffentliche Sicherheit oder nationale Sicherheit betrifft. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Krux in diesem ganzen Ding. Aber vielleicht bleiben wir erstmal beim beim Text, was denn jetzt diese Einschränkungen,
konkret ist, ne? Also sie sagen, dagegen steht das Unionsrecht nationalen Rechtsvorschriften nicht entgegen, die,
Erster Punkt, es zum Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit, gestatten,
Betreibern elektronischer Kommunikationsdienste aufzugeben, Verkehrsdaten, Verkehrs und Standort dann allgemein und unterschiedslos auf Vorrat zu speichern, wenn sich der Betreffende Mitgliedsstaat einer als real und aktuell,
oder vorhersehbaren Einzelstufen in ernsten Bedrohungen für die nationalen Sicherheit gegenübersieht. Also sagen wir mal der Russe marschiert ein.
Wenn der Russe einmarschiert, dann will ich hier nicht über Vorratsdaten diskutieren. Das sage ich dir aber jetzt schon. Da da will ich, da will ich äh die Schlüssel für die äh für die vorherige Schlösser haben.
Eine solche Anordnung kann.
Wahrscheinlich reicht das, bis die bei uns sind, brauchen wir auch echt können wir die einfach mit einem Spaten verkloppen. Na ja, okay.
Ihr Klappsparten hier. Hier steht noch eine solche Anordnung kann durch ein Gericht,
oder eine unabhängige Verwaltungsstelle kontrolliert werden und darf nur für einen auf das absolut Notwendige begrenzten aber im Fall des Fortbestands der Bedrohung, verlängerbaren Zeitraum,
ergeht. Und das ist ja so dieser typische Rechtsbuschi, ja, das absolut notwendig und das ist natürlich jetzt nicht,
definiert. Da steht jetzt nicht Stern in Klammern und dann unten Fußnote. Übrigens absolut notwendig ist Folgendes. Sondern det ist dann eben,
dieser politische Interpretationsraum und da kann man ja so ein Gericht auch verstehen, ja, weil die ja sagen, okay, also so mit,
100prozentiger Ablehnung führen wir das jetzt hier nicht durch. Es gibt Ausnahmen und dann müssen die natürlich einen Rahmen haben aber da fangen wir jetzt nicht an konkret zu werden, weil das ist ja nicht unsere Aufgabe. Wir müssen ja nur sagen, wat,
generell geht oder nicht geht. Ja so dann,
auch zweite äh Einschränkung, wo also vielleicht eine VDS in irgendeiner Form.
Zulässig wäre, ist zum Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit, zur Bekämpfung,
schwerer Kriminalität und zur Verhütung schwerer Bedrohung der öffentlichen Sicherheit,
da ist sie wieder auf der Grundlage objektiver und nicht diskriminierender Kriterien anhand von Kategorien betroffener Personen oder mittels eines,
geographischen Kriteriums für einen auf das absolut notwendige begrenzten, aber verlängerbaren Zeitraum eine gezielte Vorratsspeicherung von Verkehrs- und Standortdaten vorsehen.
Also du kannst es äh schwere Kriminalität, schwere Bedrohung der öffentlichen Sicherheit. Ähm,
ob objektiver und nicht diskriminierender Kriterien, also kann's nicht sagen, hier alle Russen, ja ähm oder vielleicht doch, aber.
Wollen oder was auch immer, genau.
Das darfst du nicht.
Und äh könntest du sogar sagen oder mittels eines geografischen Kriteriums, also zum Beispiel Sachsen. Ja ähm so na also.
So als Beispiel, normalerweise nimmt man immer das Saarland als Beispiel.
Saarland ist doch keine schwere Bedrohung.
Nee, aber ist äh auf jeden Fall ein geographische Besonderheit.
Ja, aber ist ja keine schwerwiegend schwere Bedrohung. So, da da kannst.
Na ja, also das will ich jetzt so nicht sagen, ne.
Wir können.
Oscar Lafontaine und so, also.
Von dem geht da auch keine.
Na ja, was sagst du?
Okay, aber in Ordnung. Also aufs Notwendige begrenzt, also können Sachsen temporär gezielt einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung unterziehen.
Auf Grundlage objektiver, nicht diskriminierende Kriterien. Äh von Kategorien betroffener Personen oder also entweder also wir können sagen alle Sachsen in Sachsen.
Geht. Aber er dürfen keine Ausnahmen machen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob Sie das jetzt damit gemeint haben, also geographisches Kriterium.
Ne, ich will das ja hier verm äh nachvollziehbaren Beispiel, aber verdeutlichen.
Gut, aber Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit ist sozusagen eine Bedrohung von außen, ne. Na ja, egal.
Nee, Bedrohung der öffentlichen Sicherheit. Ja, das ist jetzt ist also schwere Kriminalität, schwere Bedrohung der.
Dann ist es auch die öffentliche Sicherheit, das.
Sind wir auf der nicht mehr so ne also nationale Sicherheit kannst du das zeitlich beschränkt.
In ganz Deutschland machen.
Schwere Kriminalität und damit wird schwere Bedrohung öffentlichen Sicherheit kannst du, wenn du jetzt nicht Menschen damit diskriminierst, ja also nicht nicht diskriminierende Kategorien findest.
Gezielt machen.
Kannst du's gezielt machen und oder die andere Einschränkung, damit es gezielt ist, wäre eine Einschränkung auf einen Ort, Sachsen. Oh ja.
Außerdem für dieselben für denselben Zweck,
ist ein auf das absolut notwendige begrenzten Zeitraum eine allgemeine und unterschiedslose Speicherung der IP-Adresse.
Die der Quelle einer Verbindung zugewiesen sind vorgesehen. IP-Adressen. Mit anderen Worten.
Zu diesem Zweck ja und damit gehe ich jetzt hier schwere Kriminalität, schwere Bedrohung der öffentlichen Sicherheit. Kannst du.
Allgemein und unterschiedlichlos, also jetzt wieder im ganzen Land, äh für einen auf das Notwendige begrenzten Zeitraum,
speichern, welche IP-Adressen eine Quelle zu welchem Zeitpunkt hatte.
Das ist der Teil, die wo ich ähm der also der der im Prinzip die ähm.
Die die Anschluss die die wie heißt das, was man mit Auto macht? Führerschein? Kennzeichen?
Heißt das Kind? Nummernschild, Nummernschild, Nummernschild Pflicht im Internet, ne? Es ist ja, es ist ja tatsächlich so, es gibt eine sehr, sehr kurze Zeit, die Internetanbieterinnen speichern, wer, wann welche IP hatte?
Und danach vergessen sie es wirklich, ne? Also ein Sieg, einer der wenigen Segen von IPV4 ist, es gibt nicht genug Adressen,
Außerdem wollte man verhindern, dass Leute zu Hause Services anbieten, ja also äh hat man gesagt, wir wir machen jedem.
Alle 24 Stunden eine neue IP-Adresse, gibt's eine kurze Verbindungstrennung und dann bist du mit einer neuen IP im Internet. Und ähm,
diese Zuweisung, welche IP jetzt zu welcher Anschlusskette, also zu welchem Recht, zu welchem Menschen nehmen wir eine Rechnung schreiben, gehört, die wird nach wenigen Tagen aufgelöst. Hier geht es aber jetzt, kann man,
kann also angeordnet werden, dass diese Zuordnung bei länger gespeichert wird,
allgemein den Unterschied zu uns mit anderen Worten wieder für ganz Deutschland.
Und das hätte halt zur Folge, dass ähm wenn jetzt ihr euch mit eurer IP-Adresse irgendwohin verbindet und äh dort auf einer Webseite Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Zu einer äh,
äh schweren Kriminalität oder einer schweren Bedrohung für die für die öffentliche Sicherheit werdet oder sogar für die nationale Sicherheit, dann könnten wir sagen, hier in unseren Lok steht's, dass wir die IP, wir wollen wissen, wer das ist.
Soldatin oder hast lauter Angst aufgelegt.
Grübel gerade über den nächsten äh Absatz, den wir ein bisschen äh Schwierigkeiten bereitet.
Das klingt das mit den IP-Adressen zur zur Anschlusskennung auflösen, klingt natürlich erstmal
so ein bisschen egal, ne? Denkst du so, ja okay, komm, bei schweren Straftaten wäre schon nicht schlecht, wenn man wüsste, äh wen welcher IP gehört ja und wenn man da eine hohe
da eine hohe ähm eine hohe Hürde hat, dann wäre das ja so ein bisschen wie so eine Nummernschildpflicht, ne, an jedem Auto klebt ein Nummernschild.
Aber jetzt eine normale Person kann nicht einfach sagen, hier, ich möchte gerne wissen, wem dieses Nummernschild gehört. Du musst halt irgendwie ne, Strafanzeige oder sonst was, irgendeine Form von,
von Interesse nachweisen. Aber tatsächlich ist, wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt, ist es nämlich schon relativ einfach möglich und für unendlich viele Polizistinnen und Polizisten
problemlos möglich, die sogenannte Halterfeststellung, wenn ein Fahrzeug mal eben zu machen. Ja und das heißt, damit ist defacto.
Ähm die Anonymität im Straßenverkehr äh gegenüber dem Staat jederzeit aufgehoben,
dass äh funktioniert solange vielleicht noch in Ordnung,
bis man dann zum Beispiel so Situationen hat, dass sie ähm an der Autobahn Kennzeichnern Kennzeichenscanner hinstellen, die einfach speichern von jedem, der da vorbeigefahren ist.
Diese Kennzeichen lassen sich ja einfach für die wieder auflösen zur Person. Mit anderen Worten haben sie dann eine,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Das nur als äh wie welche Konsequenzen so etwas dann eben haben kann, wenn man diese Auflösung ermöglicht und wie gesagt, es klingt auf Anhieb nicht.
Nach keinem schweren Eingriff und es klingt auch ähm.
Das glaube ich auch hier in der Sendung schon erzählt. Ich bin ja im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit tätig, da hat man immer mal wieder mit Leuten zu tun, die Unternehmen gehackt haben und dann findet man deren IP-Adressen in den Lok
und dann denkt man, hä, was ein Idiot? Der hat äh Presse bei der Deutschen Telekom und dann siehst du ja okay, es ist ein Monat her,
Mit anderen Worten, die Person kriegst du nicht mehr, ne. Du kannst jetzt halt weiß ungefähr,
wo die sich wahrscheinlich aufgehalten hat, in welchem Bundesland oder so, ähm aber du wirst jetzt nicht mehr, du wirst nicht mehr beweisen können, dass es diese Person war.
Aber die Kehrseite eben,
De facto wäre alles, was ihr im Internet macht, immer wieder auf den Anschluss zurückführbar und das mit auf längere Zeit. Ja und da reden wir hier nicht von kurzen Zeiträumen und das hätte glaube ich schon sehr äh schwere Konsequenzen, zumal,
Die Hürden für solche Zugriffe ja immer sinken. Ja, die werden in der ersten Rechtsprechung sehr hoch gesetzt und dann kommen einfach die nachgeschobenen Gesetze, wo die ich würden für diesen Zugriff
immer weiter heruntergesetzt werden. Das ist leider der äh natürliche Lauf der Dinge. Möchtest du den nächsten Absatz.
Ja, ich äh lese ihn gleich vor. Ich blättere noch mal kurz zurück und.
Lesen wir mal den ursprünglichen, einleitenden Satz vor, ja? Also.
Der EuGH antwortet dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht, dass das Unionsrecht nationalen Rechtsvorschriften entgegensteht, die präventiv zur Bekämpfung schwerer Kriminalität und zur Verhütung.
Schwerer Bedrohungen der öffentlichen Sicherheit, eine allgemeine und unterschiedslose Vorratsspeicherung von Verkehrsunstandorten vorsehen. Also hier ist von.
Präventiv äh Bekämpfung schwerer Kriminalität und Verhütung schwerer Bedrohung der öffentlichen Sicherheit die Rede. So jetzt steht hier drin steht aber nicht entgegen,
Zum äh wenn die Regelung zum Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit zur Bekämpfung Kriminalität und zum Schutz der öffentlichen Sicherheit.
Allgemeine und unterschiedslose Vorratsspeicherung der die Identität der Nutzer elektronischer Kommunikationsmittel betreffenden Daten vorsehen.
Das ist dann die Bestandsdatenauskunft oder?
Würde ich auch mal sagen, interessant fand ich nur so die Formulierung,
Schutz der öffentlichen Sicherheit. Also oben ist von einer Bedrohung, das reicht nicht, eine Bedrohung nicht, aber zum Schutz darfst du's machen irgendwie. Also,
Das ist das ist halt irgendwie der da kennen wir uns nicht aus mit diesen ganzen Feinheiten, ne? Dürft ihr gerne mal drüber äh äh kommentieren, wenn ihr da mehr Plan habt. Ähm ist einfach schwierig mit solchen Texten. Aber kurz gesagt,
Personen, Auskunftsdaten sind irgendwie auch äh zulässig, so deute ich das mal.
Oh je und der letzte Satz ist,
Es zur Bekämpfung schwerer Kriminalität und AForte zum Schutz der nationalen Sicherheit gestatten,
den Betreibern elektronischer Kommunikationsdienste aufzugeben während eines festgelegten Zeitraums, die ihnen zur Verfügung stehenden Verkehrs- und Standortdaten umgehend zu sichern. Also
umgehend zu sichern. Das ist hier äh genau dieser dieser Ansatz, könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, ne, dass man sagt, pass auf was euch was euch anfällt, müsst ihr jetzt sichern.
Wir gucken nachher, ob wir's ob wir's uns holen, ja? Also ihr müsst es sichern. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass ihr es uns geben müsst so ungefähr.
Genau. A4 heißt erst recht, also wenn schwere Kriminalität dann natürlich auch zur nationalen Sicherheit, weil das steht da noch drüber.
Und ähm.
Eigentlich ein ganz interessanter Hinweis, dass das sozusagen, dass diese Methode äh sehr wohl hier im Blickfeld,
das EuGH ist und das erscheint mir auch nach wie vor eigentlich die einzige politische Lösung dieses Problems.
So, jetzt also zusammengefasst Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht nicht.
Wenn aber die nationale Sicherheit gefährdet ist, kannst du das im großen Stil machen,
gezielt kannst du es auch machen, zum Beispiel bei bestimmten Personen äh oder bestimmten ähm äh Orten,
beispielsweise auch, ne, jemand, der dir schon mal aufgefallen ist, dass du sagst, der, den unterziehen wir jetzt einer Fortsattenspeicherung, ne? Oder an bestimmten Orten.
Und IP-Adressenauflösungen darfst du,
ebenfalls grundsätzlich machen. Ja, das ist spezifisch in der weiteren Begründung durch das Gericht, geht es da auch äh bei der spezifisch um die Bekämpfung von Missbrauchs äh Darstellung von Kindern ähm.
Weil das ja hiermit die die Sache, dass dass da häufig erzählt wird von der Polizei. Sie äh sie hätten da eine IP-Adresse und weil sie die jetzt nicht auflösen können, äh kriegen sie die nicht. Ob das daran liegt, dass diese IP-Adresse aus einem Tornetz kommt oder so ähm.
Sieht man dann noch. Jetzt die Reaktion darauf.
Mal kurz noch eine eine Sache, also sind ja hier viele Worte drin, die man irgendwie so oder so auslegen kann. Interessant finde ich ja auch die das Adjektiv schwer. Ja.
Schwere Kriminalität. Nicht normale Kriminalität, sondern schwere Kriminalität. Die wird hier die ganze Zeit,
herangeführt. Wikipedia sagt im Artikel über Kriminalität sehr viel mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen. Äh erwähnt sie die Schwerstkriminalität,
Dies sei ein unbestimmter Begriff. Sehr hilfreich, der meistens Mord oder Bandenkriminalität umfasst.
Ja, also in in der Regel werden damit in Deutschland solche Straftaten bezeichnet, die in äh Paragraf 100 A Strafprozessordnung aufgeführt sind.
Und ja das ist äh Telekommunikationsüberwachung, ah ja. Wie passend.
Mord und Totschlag, Straftaten.
Ja, da werden da werden halt bestimmte äh also das das äh war ja damals auch diese Debatte um
Staatstrujena, Trojaner einsetzt, wo es auch ursprünglich darum ging, dass das Dubai schwerster Kriminalität ginge, ja, das war so. Und dann haben sie irgendwann gesagt, na ja oder äh oder,
Zum Beispiel wenn du eine im im verkaufst oder so ne das dann quasi von den schweren Kriminalitäts äh,
Verbrechen, ja, wo man auch sagen würde, ein Mensch, der eine solche Straftat begeht, mit dem wir zum Zweifelsfall lieber nix zu tun haben, hin zu
dem, was eher alltägliche Kriminalität ist, also der alltägliche Gesetzbruch.
Ja aber ist sehr interessant, ne? Das ist sozusagen diesen Begriff, diese Trennung von Kriminalitätsarten so nicht gab,
sondern er sich jetzt erst eigentlich im Rahmen dieser ganzen Diskussion um die Telekommunikationsüberwachung herausgebildet hat, weil man gesagt hat, okay wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie unterscheiden zwischen der Kriminalität und der Kriminalität. Da gibt's aber keine klare Trennung, also führen wir das mal hier explizit auf
äh das ist dann hier irgendwie eine Liste von äh
eins äh Absatz trallala haste nicht gesehen von A bis V wird hier irgendwie aufgezeigt. Also es ist eine richtig so eine lange äh Liste ja
Bestechlichkeit, Straftaten gegen die Landesverteidigung, gegen die öffentliche Ordnung, Geldwerzenfälschung.
Straftatverteidigung ist ja nicht mehr ein Panzerknacke, ne?
Kann schon sein du alter Panzerknacker. Mord und Totschlag, Geldwäsche.
Okay, in Ordnung, aber.
Betrug. Ich sag's nur.
Ja, ich weiß noch was. Ich du ist schön, was alles wirklich ist, ne? Okay, aber wir müssen jetzt mal vielleicht weiter beim Thema bleiben, denn es gibt jetzt Reaktionen darauf.
Und das sind die machen natürlich wenig Spaß, ne? Also.
Wir reden halt hier immer nur also wir reden hier von einer Massenüberwachung in einem Ausmaß, die wirklich irre ist, ja? Wir möchten jetzt nochmal dran erinnern, ähm.
Es gab früher Menschen, die waren gar nicht immer online und die haben vielleicht auch in ihrem Leben.
So was wie Offline-Aktivitäten gehabt. Wenn du dir überlegst, also jedes Mal, wenn du dein Handy aus der Tasche holst und irgendwie mal kurz was weiß ich, dein Essen auf Instagram postest?
Wäre das, das wäre damit die Speicherung deines Standorts in Verbindung zu bringen, ne. Also es wird das wäre das, was einfach passieren würde. Und diese das ist eine eine wirklich irre Massenüberwachung und es ist eine es war vor.
Fuffzehn Jahren oder waren diese Debatten losgingen?
Noch da war es noch nicht so schlimm, ja von weil wir tatsächlich noch, ne, da waren das irgendwie da gab's doch noch Leute, die hatten noch gar keinen äh sechs Mbit Anschluss zu Hause.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass natürlich die Leute, die auf Instagram eher Essen im Restaurant fotografieren und posten sowieso ihren Standort öffentlich to.
Ja ich möchte ich möchte dir aber ähm ich möchte auch diese Zielgruppe gewinnen, ja. Auch wenn ich nix von denen halte, möchte ich die von meinem politischen Überzeugung über überzeugen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik geht's auch Influencer freundlich.
Jetzt auch für Influencerspacken. So dann haben wir das wäre eigentlich ein schöner Claim. Logbo und Netzpolitik, auch für Influencerspacken.
Ist das nicht wieder eblestisch? Da kriegen wir doch gleich wieder auf die Nuss.
Ja stimmt, das ist kein äh es ist richtig ist äh aber äh den den Spruch habe ich von Wolfgang Kubicki. Beschwert euch bei dem. So, die der hat das ja über unseren Gesundheitsminister gesagt.
Echt. Frechheit. Schweinerei.
In seiner, aber da war der noch gar nicht Gesundheitsminister oder doch, war der.
Den doxen wir, den doxen wir.
Nee der ist mir der ist genau also jetzt schöne Reaktion also.
Georg Eisenreich, das ist der bayerische Justizminister, von der SPD, nein, CDU natürlich, ne? CSU natürlich.
Die vom EuGH eingeräumten Spielräume für die Verkehrsdatenspeicherung, insbesondere für die IP-Adressen müssen zum vor allem,
zum Schutz der Kinder vor schweren Verbrechen genutzt werden. Ja genau, die vom die vom höchsten Gericht eingeräumten Spielräume müssen sofort genutzt werden. Ähm,
Gerade im Kampf gegen Kinderpornographie und sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs seien die Daten erforderlich.
Denn jeder Fall, der nicht aufgeklärt und gestoppt werden kann, ist Orna zu viel. So, das ist ja aber,
Also ich ich mach's nochmal Tim, ja ich meine ich meine immer nur mit mit 70 werde ich hier noch sitzen und erklären, dass hier natürlich eine ein ein bewusster,
Fehlschluss gemacht wird, dass nämlich hier der Eindruck erweckt wird, dass diese Ermittlungsverfahren an der Feststellung der Anschlussinhaber von IP-Adressen scheitern würden. Wir wissen ja aber, dass es nicht so ist.
Wir wissen ja, dass die sich über das Darknet äh austauschen und dass die IP-Adressen, die du da findest, in der Regel,
Welche sind von irgendwelchen Torservern, die irgendwo im Internet stehen? So, das heißt, du es
es wird auch durch diese Massenüberwachung ist ist das ist die gleiche Argumentation wie bei der Chatkontrolle. Auch hier wird es wieder nicht erfasst werden. Es es ist wieder etwas, wo die,
die ähm die Kriminellen schon längst weiter sind.
Und diese Überwachung einfach nur die Bürgerinnen und Bürger treffen würde und es wird hier der Eindruck vermittelt und der ist natürlich da haben natürlich alle ein Interesse dran. Die ganzen Versagerpolizistinnen und Polizisten die die Fälle nicht aufklären,
Sagen natürlich, ja, das lag daran, das ist ja klar. Da sind da sind mir ja die Hände gebunden. Ich bin ja ein guter Polizist, aber ich habe ich habe halt leider keine Vollüberwachung der gesamten Bevölkerung. Äh deswegen geht das nicht, also brauchen wir eine volle Überwachung der gesamten Bevölkerung. Hauptsache es liegt nicht an mir.
Ähm gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich auch einfach mal Kriminelle, die technische Mittel nutzen, um,
sich äh der Strafverfolgung zu entziehen. Ja, das hat es immer gegeben, in egal welchen Technisierungsgrad die Menschheit und die Strafverfolgung zu unserem Schutz hatte,
hatte die gleichen Technologisierungsgrad natürlich auch die die Kriminelle äh Komponente unserer Gesellschaft,
sich dagegen wehrt. Ja, also wir werden nie eine vollständige Aufklärung bekommen. Das heißt, diesen Satz den kann der
in einem Jahr, in zehn Jahren, in 100 Jahren wiederholen, wenn er die nächste Grundrechtseinschränkung fordert, weil es immer und immer so sein wird, dass wir keine hundertprozentigen Aufklärungsquoten haben. Und dann kann er immer wieder diesen Satz sagen und das nächste fordern, ja, was weiß ich
biometrische Erfassung, äh wenn du den Computer anfasst oder Videoüberwachung am Bahnhof mit Bibelfischer Erkennung, das wird er immer sagen können, ja?
Aber es ist es wird hier quasi der Eindruck erweckt, dass dass dass man dass man diese Vollaufklärung erreichen könnte.
Der bayrische Innenminister äh geht da natürlich auch direkt hin und sagt,
ideologisch übertriebener Datenschutz wäre falsch verstandener Täterschutz?
Ja, also geht sofort äh äh auf die auf die Menschen, die hier die versuchen, die Verfassungsrechte zu schützen. Das darf sich ein Rechtsstaat nicht leisten. Pervertiert das also, ne, sagt,
wir dürfen als Rechtsschutz, wir dürfen als Rechtsstaat und uns nicht leisten, dass wir diese Grundrechte haben, weil das wäre ja Städterschutz,
Ähm und er müsste jetzt,
und dann kommt er auch wieder und an diesem Satz merkst du auch, dass der Typ halt auch keine Ahnung hat, wovon er redet. Unsere Ermittler von Polizei und Justiz brauchen zur Bekämpfung bestimmter schwerer Straftaten unbedenkt Verkehrsdaten,
VIP-Adressen.
IP-Adresse ist ja wiederum das ist ja kein Verkehrsdatum, das ist ja ein äh das ist weißt du es ist so.
Und er wird jetzt äh am 27. September, also am Montag in München,
oder ist das Montag, der siebenundzwanzigste, nee, Dienstag äh wird er sofort bei der Innenministerkonferenz äh,
das Thema zum Schwerpunkt machen. Ehrlich gesagt ich glaube nicht, dass der Joachim Herrmann das jetzt spontan zum Schwerpunkt macht,
wenn ein paar Tage nach dem Urteil eine Innenministerkonferenz ist. Ich würde vermuten, die findet genau an dem Datum statt, weil alle wussten, wann dieses Urteil kommt.
Also ne, da wird jetzt hier diese äh wird wird sofort mit allen möglichen Bandagen gekämpft und sehr relativ ungeniert auch äh davon gesprochen. Da muss man sich dem Bundesjugendjustizminister Marco Buschmann loben.
Der sagt, guter Tag für die Bürgerrechte,
historisches Urteil bestätigt, anlasslose Vorortsdatensprechung ist rechtswidrig, ja. Was man ja auch mal feststellen muss, da wurde grade mal wieder ein Gesetz von Deutschland, wofür die jahrelang gekämpft haben, gegen jeden Protest mal wieder kassiert.
Und jetzt sagt er, dieses Instrument muss nun zügig und endgültig aus dem Gesetz raus. Hat er natürlich recht. Er selbst ähm,
tritt ein für die sogenannte Quickfreas-Regelung.
Die äh wie wir sagten, wo man sich im Prinzip so einen flüchtigen Speicher vorstellen muss, ne, da gibt's dann,
rauscht das alles durch, sagen wir mal, der hat eine der hat eine eine Zeit von einer Woche ja also eine Woche unterliegen wir alle der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Aber eben auch nur diese eine Woche und wenn es in dieser einen Woche, ich nehme die Woche jetzt als als Beispiel, wenn in dieser Woche auf einmal ein Interesse an deiner PRIP-Adresse äh Ermittlungsbehörden kommt, dann sagen sie, ey
dieser IP bitte jetzt einfrieren und weiterlaufen lassen. Da könnte man also dann quasi eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf den Anschluss, ne, wäre gezielt.
Ähm ansetzen, ja? So könntest du also sehen, was weiß ich, irgendwie äh.
Ja von der von einer IP einer IP taucht in einem Verbrechen auf, dann kann man sagen, hier ist der Anschluss, jetzt bitte sofort feststellen, die Daten der letzten Woche festhalten, statt sie jetzt äh zu
zu löschen und dann für diesen äh
Zeitraum des Ermittlungsverfahrens oder so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wir werden uns die dann nachher mit äh Richterbeschluss holen. Das äh wäre,
der Punkt, ja? Das ist ein vollkommen gangbares, sinnvolles Verfahren
eben einen bestimmten Zeitraum offen lässt für die Benennung einer IP-Adresse?
Und dann eben eine nach vorne gehende Vorratsdatensprechung eines Anschlusses. Die wiederum nicht. Die ganze Bevölkerung anlasslos betrifft. Ja ein äh seit ähm langer Zeit äh von vielen
Vertretender Vorschlag ähm ich weiß auch, dass ich da mal, ich glaube, ich hätte da Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte war das denn.
Äh oder war das gar nicht,
sondern haben sich auch schon einige Datenschutzbeauftragte für eingesetzt, weil sie sagen so, da kannst du das gleiche Ergebnis mit haben.
Und ähm du überwachst nicht die ganze Bevölkerung.
Das ist vor allem auch durchaus vorstellbar, dass man da belastbare Speichermodelle,
macht, was nicht, was da jetzt schon alles diskutiert wurde, aber wenn man da mal so schnell drüber nachdenkt so, aha okay, es soll also die ganze Zeit Daten erstmal geschrieben werden, aber sie sollen irgendwie flüchtig sein, dann könnte man sich halt irgendein System überlegen, wo was weiß ich zentral irgendwelche Verschlüsselungs
Schlüssel ausgegeben werden nach dem Motto ja verschlüsselt das mal heute damit so und der Schlüssel wird halt einfach global,
Nach einer Woche weggeschmissen und existiert nicht mehr.
Und dann kann er sonst was auf den Festplatten stehen, kriegst du's nicht mehr entschlüsselt so. Ne, so irgend so ein Modell, wo einfach Daten dann einfach invalide werden und dann auch für niemanden mehr zu gebrauchen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich sage dir mal eins, von Verschlüsselung brauchst du hier nur gar nicht zu reden. Also.
Also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das auch noch irgendwie mit vernünftiger Verschlüsselung gemacht wird. Du kannst kannst einfach sagen, was weiß ich, du bist der Internetprovider, du hast die eine SSD für du hast du hast sieben SSDs.
Oder 7 Cluster aus SSDs und äh,
Jeden Tag nimmst du ein anderes und nach nach sieben Tagen bist du wieder bei dem ersten oder so. Aber sag mal, ich glaube die technische Umsetzung brauchen wir jetzt hier nicht nicht unbedingt zu diskutieren. Ähm es geht ja darum, wer ist äh wann äh,
ne, wann wer wird, wann er fastt. Dem entgegnet Nancy Phaser die und jetzt muss ich's leider auch mal langsam sagen, die in diesem Bereich nun wirklich einfach mal keine Ahnung hat,
Ich habe das ja versucht, sehr äh diplomatisch äh auszudrücken, als es die Bilanz getroffen habe, ne? Man kann sich das ja anschauen, ähm dass sie.
Nicht also dass ihr auch auf meine Frage,
Als ich hier sage, wollen sie Bestandsdatenauskunft verlängern? Wollen sie Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Was wollen sie genau machen? Und auch die drei Optionen noch mal erläutere, weil ich denke okay, vielleicht wenn ich dir die drei Sachen sage, dann wird's ja vielleicht
so ungefähr erkennen, äh was äh aus dem feindlich besetzten Haus, das unter ihr arbeitet, ähm man ihr gesagt hat
Was sie machen soll und er sagt sie einfach nur, ja alpierte das, wir brauchen IP-Adressen. Leute, ihr habt IP-Adressen, was so das also,
Jetzt antwortet sie auf die Regelung mit dem Satz,
wenn die Daten weg sind, kann ich auch nichts mehr einfrieren. Das ist das Problem. Ja mit anderen Worten, sie hat auch das wieder nicht verstanden, ne?
Also es ist es ist das ist dramatisch, ne?
Ja, aber das ist der Grund, warum ich auch grad so einen technischen Vorschlag mal gemacht habe, um es mal einfach mal zu konkretisieren, ne.
Dann wird ihr gesagt, liebe Frau Felser, ne, äh vielleicht haben Sie,
Sie sich noch dran erinnern, dass es ein äh äh Koalitionsvertrag gibt, in dem drin steht.
Dass Daten nur anlassbezogen gespeichert werden dürfen, ja? Also nur anders bezogen und jetzt sagt sie,
Das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren. Stimmt, kann man nicht. Kann man nicht. Aber dann ist sie noch nicht fertig. Es geht ja auch darum, dass wir nur Anlass bezogen eingreifen,
Das ist ja die Unterscheidung. Es kann es geht ja nicht darum, dass wir uns die Daten aller Menschen angucken, sondern wir wollen ja nur bei schwerer Kriminalität die Daten nutzen.
Insofern gibt uns der Spielvertrag Spielraum. Nein, gib dir nicht. Ganz äh wenn da steht, das wird nicht Anlass. Es wird ein Anlass bezogen gespeichert,
Dann sagt sie, nee voll geil, wir speichern einfach von allen und greifen dann anders bezogen zu, dann hat sie ja nicht also ihr kennt noch nicht mal den Unterschied zwischen Speichern und Zugriff.
Aber ihr erster Satz,
lässt ja vermuten, dass sie einen Unterschied zwischen Speichern und Zugriff erkennt, denn sie weiß ja, wenn die Daten weg sind, kann ich nichts mehr einfrieren, ne, wenn nicht mehr gespeichert,
nicht mehr zugreifen. Aber also sie kennt den Unterschied ja aber äh ein Satz später äh ist es schon nicht mehr gegeben. Das ist es ist wirklich katastrophal und ich habe das ja hier öfter schon gesagt. Das liegt.
Es äh und ich muss jetzt nochmal sagen, ne, wenn du,
Politikerin bist oder äh äh Innenminister, auch Ministerin, egal in welchem Bereich, ja? Du bist nicht die absolute Expertin auf dem Gebiet, ist völlig klar.
Der Robert Habeck ist auch nicht der absolute Experte in allen Bereichen von Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und was er da alles macht, ja? Das Entscheidende ist,
er sich die richtigen Leute dafür sucht in seinem politischen Sinne hier Lösungen zu finden und mal gelingt Ihnen das, vielleicht gelingt's ihm auch nicht. Nancy Fesa übernimmt die Hütte von äh von
Horst Seehofer und denkt mit den Leuten könnte man arbeiten. Das ist das Problem.
Ähm und der jetzt kommt der Knüller, ja
Wir haben jetzt gesagt, ne? Sie die die bayrische Innenminister und Justizminister kommen sofort. Ja, die Kinder, die Kinder, die Killer, die Killer, wir müssen alle überwachen die Kinder, den den
Kinder sind diesen alten Säcken doch scheißegal. Das muss ich ja sowieso sagen. Entsprechend sagt dann und dann kommt der deutsche Kinderschutzbund, ja die sich mit Kinderschutz auseinandersetzen und sagen,
Wir sprechen der Innenministerin. Ich meine zu diesem CDUler äh CSUler äußern die sich gar nicht, ne? Der Kinderschutzbund hält das sogenannte Verfahren für einen gangbaren Weg. In der Abwägung zwischen Datenschutz und Kinderschutz. So, das heißt
sogar der Kinderschutzbund ähm sagt,
hier so Leute, vielleicht könnten wir mal eine sinnvolle äh Überlegung machen, ne. Vielleicht könnten wir hier.
Und es hat übrigens auch nicht nur ich kann auch Datenschutz nicht mehr hören. Ich kann ja seit Jahren schon nicht mehr hören, ne? Es geht hier nicht. Es es geht hier das das war das Einzige, was mich wirklich mal wirklich interessiert hat als ähm.
Äh unser alter äh Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter vor, Peter Scha,
Genau. Peter Stadier sagte, es geht hier nicht um irgendeine um irgendein komisches Konzert, es geht hier um Grundrecht.
Ne und schwierig, okay, aber ähm.
Ist schon komisch, dass der politische Kompromiss es eigentlich seit Jahren aufm Tisch.
Ja.
Wird nicht gegangen. Stattdessen beschließt man immer wieder das Gleiche dann wird dagegen geklagt, dann geht es zum EuGH, der EuGH sagt, Alter, Alter, schöne Grüße vom Murmeltier.
Und dann geht die ganze Reihe wieder von äh vorne los mit.
So und der der der Begriff wurde zum ersten Mal interessant ähm.
Begriff äh wurde zuerst in einer deutschen Diplomarbeit aus dem Jahr 2tausend3 verwendet, die sie unterm auf ein Interview mit Scott Shani, dem Vorsitzenden der G-Arbeitsgruppe Hightech Kriminalität auf dem aus dem Jahr 1999 bezieht.
Ähm so das heißt, äh also diese Idee wir machen packen den auch noch mal.
Jahre.
20 Jahre liegt diese Idee da, ne? Und und du hast diese du hast da, das musst du dir auch mal überlegen, also mal ganz im Ernst, ne?
Es gibt ja offenbar Menschen, das sind politische äh Strategen oder was auch immer, ja, die inzwischen.
Ja tatsächlich, 20 Jahre ihrer politischen Einflussnahme in die deutsche Demokratie, dem Thema widmen eine Vorratsdatenschwächung einzuführen,
Und wenn man jetzt also ich meine so abwege ich dieses Ziel sowieso schon ist ne aber wenn man mal sagt das ist dein Ziel. Gut,
das ist das du möchtest das zeitliche segnen und sagen das habe ich Deutschland gebracht, das war gut, jetzt kann ich zufrieden sterben, ne? Wenn wenn das dein Ziel ist, ne und.
Und es liegt seit 20 Jahren liegt da jemand und sagt pass auf so können wir's machen kriegst du die gleichen Ziele ungefähr hin,
nur du bist sich irgendwie du hast kein und du hast potenziell einfach gar keine Probleme mit dem mit den äh Verfassungsgericht, weißt ja alles ist ja alles geklärt. Ist ja auch alles schon hundertmal geurteilt worden, ne? Hier wäre eine Lösung, wo du wie du dein politisches Ziel,
erreichen kannst, ja? Diese, wenn es dir wirklich an der Lösung des Problems liegt, ja? Und dann sitzt er Leute und sagt, nein, nein, das wollen wir nicht.
Kommt überhaupt nicht in Frage. Äh wir wollen wir wollen alles. Wir wollen alles oder nichts. Wir sind lieber bereit zwanzig Jahre Deutschland ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu dulden,
Als dass wir einfach mal ein funktionierendes System nehmen, was äh was äh Grund- und Menschenrechte achtet.
Also mit solchen Leuten würde ich eh ehrlich gesagt nicht zusammenarbeiten. Die erscheinen mir politisch unklug. Dem würde ich auch kein Geld geben.
Ehrlich. Überleg mal, wie doof die wie dumm die sind. Also es ist ja wirklich keine kluge, kein kluges Verhalten, ne. So, jetzt äh immer wieder, nein wir machen.
Wir machen nochmal hier ein fettes Vorratsdatensprechungsgesetz. Vielleicht vielleicht merken Sie's diesmal nicht.
Nennen wir es mal anders, den Versuch gab's ja auch, ne? Mindestdatenspeicherung und was da noch äh zwischendurch so an verraten kam mit irgendwie ja mhm cooler Trick. Das ist einfach anders nennen.
Sechs Uhr und der Tag fängt wieder von vorne an.
Mal äh zu den zu den Themen äh also,
Es ist ja tatsächlich ich sage das auch ganz ganz offen und ehrlich. Ich habe seit äh.
Jeher oder nicht seit jeher, aber seit vielen Jahren äh geht mein Internet durch ein ein VPN. Ja, also ich äh ich rate ja immer davon ab, VPNs zu nutzen von kommerziellen Anbietern.
Aber so was kann man sich auch selber machen und ähm zumindest, sage ich mal, für,
wahrscheinlich ist es paradoxerweise so, wenn wir jetzt zu einem kommerziellen Anbrüter geht, dass man wahrscheinlich
erstmal noch mehr über oder eines einen günstigen kommerziellen Anbieter gibt, dass man wahrscheinlich erstmal noch mehr Überwachung unterliegt, als man äh unterliegt, wenn man
Wenn man einen deutschen normalen Festnetzanschluss nutzt, ja, aber äh wie dem auch sei, ich äh habe,
für mich eine Lösung gefunden, bevor jetzt wieder alle fragen, nein, wir sind nicht äh irgendwie ein Werbepodcast. Ich werde euch auch nicht sagen, welchen VPN-Anbieter ich benutze oder welche nicht euch empfehlen würde. Ihr kriegt auch keinen Code,
den ihr eingeben müsst, um dann 20Prozent zu kriegen und ihr dürft unseren Podcast sogar hören und uns Geld zu geben. Aber äh ich würde mich langsam vorbereiten,
weil was wahrscheinlich kommen wird, wenn die nicht weiterhin so blöd sind, ähm ist mindestens so eine Quickfree-Regelung,
wenn nicht tatsächlich also wenn sie wenn sie nicht wirklich so dämlich sind dass sie noch ein weiteres Mal,
eine ähm Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen, die den die den die den Urteil nicht äh äh entspricht, auf die sie immer gewartet haben.
Deswegen möchten wir ein bisschen darüber sprechen, wie man äh der Überwachung,
und auch in diesem Fall allerdings eher der Zensur entgehen kann. Tim, wir sprechen über,
Die technischen Maßnahmen im Iran. Ich denke, was im Iran gerade los ist, ist allen oder ist vielen bekannt.
Vielleicht auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, also der konkrete äh Vorfall, der jetzt zu Unruhen führt in äh im Iran, während wir hier sprechen, ist die äh Ermordung einer jungen Frau im Iran von äh der,
Sitten.
Polizei.
Ja, weil sie irgendwie ihr Kopftuch nicht tragen wollte und dann ist sie halt irgendwie festgenommen und malträtiert worden, als dabei gestorben und das hat halt so großen Unruhen geführt, die zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, während wir jetzt diese Sendung aufnehmen.
Glaube nicht, dass die dabei gestorben ist. Ich glaube, die ist daran gestorben.
Daran, wie auch immer, sie ist auf jeden Fall gestorben und das hat dann einfach äh Unruhen ausgelöst und zwar Unruhen, wie sie der Iran schon lange nicht mehr gesehen hat, teilweise auch wie
seit der islamischen Revolution, wenn ich das richtig sehe, so in der Form auch noch überhaupt nicht stattgefunden haben. Es geht also rund und natürlich hat der äh Iran teilweise mit Internetabschaltungen reagiert, aber eben auch mit Sperren von Messengern.
Und natürlich herrscht wahrscheinlich generell auch eine gewisse Überwachungssituation, was die Nutzung des Internets betrifft. Darüber habe ich jetzt keine konkrete Kenntnis, bloß.
Auch über andere Kanäle wurde an mich an dich wahrscheinlich auch in irgendeiner Form Fragen gestellt wieder so was kann man denn da machen? Was kann man denn da tun.
Ja, da gibt es also zwei also Signal hat ähm äh selber quasi auch direkt dazu aufgerufen, was man am besten äh machen kann, um dieser.
Zensur von Signal äh entgegenzutreten.
Also keine Zensur, sondern es ist eher eine Blockade der der Signalserver.
Also ja okay.
Stimmt, ja. Ja, ich glaube, Zensur wäre was das Löschen einzelner. So wird einfach der gesamte Service geblockt und sie sagen, okay, hier ähm,
Du kannst einen relativ einfachen äh TLS Proxy aufsetzen, der den die Blockade um,
verhindert ja und haben also eine eine Anleitung auch gegeben mit einem äh TLS Proxy,
der dann äh als Docker-Container äh hochgefahren wird und der macht im Prinzip auf Pot achtzig und äh vier vier drei macht er auf auf achtzig lenkt er dann natürlich einfach oder macht er ja,
auf achtzig und vier vier drei auf auf achtzig wirft der Lenker einfach um auf vier vier drei, was der Powert wäre für normales HTTPS und dann.
Sieht es also so aus als hätte man eine SSL-Verbindung mit einem anderen Server und der eben nicht blockiert wird.
Noch, noch nicht blockiert wird
ja gleichzeitig rufen sie aber dazu auf, man möge dann das Twittern unter einem bestimmten Hashtag, was ich jetzt äh auf Anhieb denke, okay,
dieses dieses Hashtag äh würde ich glaube ich verfolgen, wenn ich der
der Blocker wäre, aber so ist es immer ein Katz und Maus Spiel, ja? Also Signal relativ einfache Anleitung,
und dann wird also der Teil der Kommunikation, der noch mit Signal laufen muss, ja? Signal muss ja irgendwo,
zentral sagen, jo, du bist jetzt gerade angemeldet, du bist erreichbar, hier ist ein Anruf für dich und so weiter. Dieser Teil geht dann eben durch,
einen spezifischen Proxideen, aber die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer immer noch einstellen müssen, ja und das finde ich auch, also das finde ich immer ein bisschen, dass ähm.
Ja gewissermaßen das Dramatische an solchen Fällen, dass du.
Jetzt eine technische Lösung spontan in Reaktion bereitstellen kannst, aber dass dass die trotzdem so viele Menschen nicht erreichen wird, ne, weil die jetzt da sitzen, die stellen auf einmal fest, äh Signal funktioniert nicht mehr.
Ja gut.
Ich freue mich ehrlich gesagt, warum Single nicht äh gleich eine Technologie aufsetzt, wo solche Proxis automatisch gefunden werden können.
Ja und jetzt kommen wir nämlich, also super, genau, jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Problem, wenn die Praxis automatisch gefunden werden können, ja?
Dann.
Den anderen gefunden werden.
Werden Sie natürlich auch von den anderen gefunden. Das ist der das ist der Punkt wie du auch relativ effektiv Tor in einem Land sperren kannst
Da nämlich der die Verbindung zum Tor Netzwerk,
abhängig davon ist, dass du Entry Notes hast, von denen es halt nur so und so viele gibt, ja, also eine endliche Anzahl erschreckend geringe endliche Anzahl, die du, wenn du jetzt es als Start möchtest, potentiell auch alles sperren kannst.
Deswegen ähm kann man,
sogenannte Tor Bridges betreiben, also das sind Entry Notes, die nicht offiziell gelistet sind,
Und wenn du dann jetzt quasi in einem Land bist, wo äh dass das also Tor blockiert, ja, was kommst du an, machst Internet, Tor auf und dann steht da, ja, hier Tor, kann ich kann keine Verbindung herstellen.
Guck doch mal, ob du nicht vielleicht eine Bridge nutzen möchtest, dann setzt du dich mit tollen Verbindungen und dann sagen die dir, eine.
Eine von ihren nichtöffentlich gelisteten Bridges, um um eben langsam diesen Pool ähm,
abzubauen, ja und und dann irgendwie oder um quasi den nicht sofort potenziell den Blockiererinnen äh zur Verfügung zu stellen,
Jetzt gibt's aber noch eine andere Technik und die nennt sich ähm Snow Flake und die sieht tatsächlich ähm um einiges äh also sieht sieht relativ vielversprechend aus ähm.
Und das funktioniert so, dass Sie ein du bist also ein ähm.
Du hast einen äh Browser Plugin oder eine du kannst auch diese gleiche Funktionalität in eine Webseite einbauen. Da müssen Leute nur diese Webseite besuchen,
und ähm können dadurch ihre Bandbreite zur Verfügung stellen und was das ist, ist quasi ein Ersatz für Bridges. Also du hast ähm
du musst nicht eine eigene Software nutzen sondern ähm es geht,
Es geht quasi über Web RTC, was ein Protokoll ist, was heute eigentlich für Video äh Übertragung und so was äh gedacht ist und darüber tunneln sie dich dann einfach in das Tor Netz rein. Das heißt, wenn du das aufmachst,
nimmt deinen Computer, dein Browser, dieses Plug-in Web RTC-Verbindung von anderen an, die ad hoc,
aussehen einfach erstmal wie eben Anrufe und schmeißt sich auf der anderen Seite dann einfach in in ein Tor rein
Also in das in das Tor Netz. Warum macht man das so? Erstens weil's super elegant ist, weil äh ist schön und zweitens habe ich ja gerade schon zum Thema Fortzeitenspeicherung erzählt, unsere IP-Adressen erinnern sich die ganze Zeit. Das heißt, ähm.
Um zu erkennen, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir möchten das blockieren, müsste man erstmal erkennen, dass dass da jetzt gerade eine IP-Adresse
diesen Service anbietet und die hat demnächst nach ein paar Tagen eh wieder eine andere IP-Adresse und ähm so
scheint, das ist erstmal glaube ich ein ein Schritt weiter. Das ist tatsächlich relativ ähm.
Relativ gute Idee erstmal, dieses ähm.
Dieses Snow Flag. Allerdings habe ich das bei mir jetzt mal angemacht und Tim, du meintest, da wird dann irgendwann gezeigt, wie viele Leute,
wie vielen Leuten man bei der Zensur Umgehung hilft. Bei mir steht null, also da steht aber es passiert nichts.
Ich hab's mal äh ausprobiert und da war dann so nach einer Stunde waren da so sechs, 7 aufgeführt.
Vor Beginn der Sendung angemacht. Die Sendung ist jetzt schon über eine Stunde.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht sind jetzt ja schon wieder komplett abgeschaltet.
Vielleicht trauen sie auch meinem meinem zweifelhaften IP-Adressbereich hier nicht.
Kann sein, ja.
Okay, aber da gibt's also gibt's schöne Funktionen und äh das Einzige, was ich da nur zu sagen würde, es ist eben sehr äh,
sehr sehr bedauerlich gewissermaßen, dass man das dann immer erst ad hoc macht, weil dann ist es, dann ist es schon zu spät. Und da gefällt mir dieser dieser Snowfleck-Ansatz wirklich sehr ähm weil du,
die kriegst du also als äh Plug-in für Firefox und Chrome.
Und das könnte man einfach mal so machen, ne und dann äh.
Weißt du dann, dann wenn man das drin hat, dann kann man das glaube ich äh also dann dann läuft's einfach und dann hat man schon längst wieder vergessen und dann muss man nicht, wenn wenn das Problem,
passiert,
oder wenn das wenn das Problem auftritt ad hoc etwas machen, weil so ein kleines Plug-in mehr oder weniger ist bei den meisten Leuten egal, die sammeln die ja wie andere Leute Briefmarken.
Und ihr müsst euch da auch jetzt keine Gedanken machen, dass ihr jetzt von irgendjemand für irgendwas entdeckt werdet in dem Zusammenhang, ihr plagt euch quasi nur in dieses tollen Netzwerk rein. Ihr seid da äh kein Exit Not.
Könnt dementsprechend auch nicht belangt werden für irgendwas.
Und äh um da reinzukommen, also um über Snow Flag dann auch Tor zu nutzen. Das kann der Torbrowser äh für für Desktop und Android, also der.
Der klassische Torbrowser, der Onion Browser und iOS, also das ist äh und Orbot äh verändert und IOS-Obot ist,
macht. Also der Onion Browser ist halt ein Browser und ORBOT macht das registriert das als System VPN. Dann kannst du auch andere Apps dadurch werfen. Und mein Vermutung ist, jetzt muss ich vorsichtig sein, aber so wie sich das liest, kannst du vermutlich.
ORBOT auf deinem IOS laufen lassen, das verbindet sich dann über Snow Flake und dann sagst du deinem.
Signal, dann geht dein Signal durch dieses theoretische VPN und dann müsste es auch schon wieder funktionieren,
Also Orbot äh müsste das lösen können, aber das äh,
Da gehe ich jetzt gerade nur von aus. Da müsste man nochmal schauen, ob das äh ob das auch tatsächlich so ist.
Ja, haben wir die Frage beantwortet. Ansonsten,
wünsche ich der wünsche ich mir eine iranische Revolution und die Befreiung aller Iranerinnen. Das wollte ich an dieser Stelle nochmal ganz klar sagen und dieses Scheißregime dat wird echt Zeit, dass das mal äh weg ist und es für das
ganz ganz äh toll,
die Bilder zu sehen, wie die da ihr äh ihre Kopftücher verbrennen und tanzen und ähm das ist äh sehr sehr beeindruckend. Ähm was da gerade passiert und man kann nur hoffen,
es ist äh dem Regime nicht gelingt, diese äh Zahnpasta wieder in die Tube zu drücken.
Schauen wir mal.
Bleiben wir bei Überwachung in Deutschland.
Drei Überwachungsthemen, ne?
Zwei mit Video, ja. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass am 1. Mai 2019 in Berlin Grunewald äh die S-Bahn-Station mit den ganzen Demonstrierenden gefilmt wurde. Dagegen,
hat sich das Quartiersmanagement Grunewald und des äh Pfiff,
Form, Informatikerin für freiheitliche, für Frieden und freiheitliche Gesellschaft. Ich ich werd's mir nie merken können. Pfiff ist halt Pfiff, so.
Kennt man. Äh ist auch schon lange dabei. So und die haben ja dagegen geklagt.
Und äh habe jetzt in der ersten Instanz äh verloren, ja ähm und müssen jetzt äh also das das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin,
sagte, ja nee ähm siebeneinhalbtausend Demoteilnehmerinnen mit schwenkbaren Zoom-Kameras auf dem Weg zur Versammlung zu filmen,
das geht klar, das darf man,
Und ähm jetzt wird werden natürlich das äh Pfiff und das Quartiersmanagement Grunewald dagegen in Berufung gehen, also für das vor das Oberverwaltungsgericht Berlin,
Brandenburg sich gegen dieses Urteil aussprechen. Ja, weil Argumente wiederhole ich nochmal, ne, diese Videoüberwachung dient,
einer Anwesenheitsliste, einer Demonstration und,
ich das hat einen guten Grund, warum man das nicht möchte, warum man so etwas nicht,
macht und äh ich will natürlich nicht sagen, dass im äh Grunewald iranische Verhältnisse herrschen.
Aber wenn man sich das im Iran anschaut, dann weiß man auch, warum man nicht möchte, dass ähm Demonstrierende äh.
Identifiziert, polizeilich katalogisiert werden. Was äh übrigens im Iran jetzt auch gerade stattfindet, es gibt halt so eine Telegram-Gruppe, wo die äh ja die Sittenpolizei oder wie die sich da nennen, äh quasi.
Bitten um Bilder und Identifikationen von den Demonstrierenden, also dass man sagt, macht Fotos von denen und sagt, wo die wohnen.
Ja, es äh noch nicht mal so lustig. Aber es gibt ja noch andere Videokameras, weil weißt du.
Leute überwachen sich heutzutage schon selbst. Nicht nur die Influencer im Restaurant.
Es ist das ist so geil. Also die die ja das ist ja auch wirklich so ein so ein Fass Faszinationsding. Ähm.
Ist eine also der der sagen wir mal der Markt für für,
mit Videokamera, der war ja wirklich reif für eine für eine Revolution. Ja, wenn ich ähm wenn ich bei uns irgendwie diese diese Türklingel und nee, wie heißt'n nicht,
sprechen, nicht wieder Sprechanlage, denn.
So was bräuchten wir mal die Widersprechanlage. Muss man nicht die ganze Zeit immer einen Podcast aufnehmen drücken einfach auf die Widersprechanlage und dann wird widersprochen.
Widersprecher
Okay, also die Wechselschritte also dieser Markt war äh bereit für für eine äh Revolution und äh mit IP und äh äh ein paar Sensoren kann man da relativ schnell was was Schönes bauen
Gab's irgendwie ein Start-up, die haben diese gebaut, wurden dann von Amazon gekauft und das Ergebnis ist jetzt, dass es an an vielen Haustüren, ich glaube, primär auch in den USA eher,
äh Kameras an der Tür gibt, die halt einen Klingelknopf haben und deren Hauptanwendungszweck darin besteht,
Amazon-Fahrer dabei zu filmen, wie sie Scheiße mit den Paketen umgehen, um sie dann an Amazon zu verpfeifen, damit sie ihren Job loswerden, ne?
Und auf YouTube zu hochzuladen. Das scheint mir der primär Anwendungszweck von.
Ja, ich glaube mit der Primärade mit dem Speck ist, dass die Amazon-Pakete dann immer von irgendwelchen Leuten geklaut werden, weil es in den USA irgendwie noch Gang und Gäbe ist, die Zulieferung, wenn jemand nicht zu Hause ist,
Auf der Front zu machen, die ja so amerikanische Häuser gerne haben und äh dann werden die da halt einfach abgestellt. Da gibt's so Leute, die laufen einfach rum, sehen so, oh, das Paket, das nehme ich mir mal mit.
Ja. Da geht's ja von dem, ach, wie heißt denn, Nachname? Mark diese Glitterbomben.
Ja ja, die Glitterbomben sind super.
Die sind super. Das ist der, dass der humorvolle Umgang damit, ja. Äh so, jetzt aber jetzt musste der natürlich.
Marc Rover. Äh kennt ihr wahrscheinlich sehr populärer äh Youtuber, der sich immer einen Spaß draus macht
so Pakete, die dann eben auf der stehen und du darauf warten von irgendjemand geklaut zu werden, technisch so auszustatten, dass wenn man die dann öffnet, dass ihr mit allen möglichen Scheiß ausgestattet sind. Da hat er jetzt, glaube ich, schon irgendwie die Version vier null
rausgebracht das Ding äh macht dann irgendwie Sounds äh macht irgendwie äh
auf so einen Zerstäuber für äh Stinke äh Spray und wirft vor allem halt so mit so Glitter um sich.
Und hat Handys drin und filmt das Ganze.
Genau. Flip das Ganze mit GPS und volles Programm und setzt dann halt irgendwie die Polizei an, irgendwie diese Leute wiederzufinden. Also das ist schon sehr unterhaltsam und äh hat auch einen extrem hohen Nerd.
Ja und der also der Typ ist einfach, der also der ist wirklich der Knüller. Ich glaube, ist auch einer der ganz großen äh YouTube-Stars. Äh inzwischen ehemaliger NASA-Mitarbeiter,
So und äh genau, der hat auf jeden Fall ach wird jetzt nicht Markt Videos. Ähm.
Der hat den coolen Ansatz dafür, ja und ist eher der uncoole Ansatz, denn,
auch in Deutschland gibt's ring.
Kundenvideos ohne Gerichtsbeschluss weiter an die Bullen. Was ich wäre echt geil vorstelle, weil.
Wenn du dir so ein Ding an die Tür machst, ne. Ist ja schön und gut, aber du musst dir auch darüber im Klaren sein. Die Person, die das Ding am meisten überwacht, bist du selber. Weil du du bist mit Abstand,
Personen, die am häufigsten deine Tour nutzt. Türen nutzt, ne? Und du bist natürlich auch jedes Mal da drauf.
Und ja, wenn die äh wenn die Strafverfolgung eine unmittelbare Bedrohung nachweisen kann und die Zeit drängt, äh gibt äh Amazon eben diese diese Daten raus.
Cloud abgespeichert werden, ich muss zugeben, ich bin mit den einzelnen Produkten nicht so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ding nicht also.
Es gibt, glaube ich, auch gibt's mir so Hacks, dass man das auch wieder lokal machen kann, aber der normale Fall ist, dass die Dinger halt unverschlüsselt äh bis zu 180 Tage äh in der Cloud gespeichert werden.
Das Problem ist natürlich an der Stelle unverschlüsselt. Das ist natürlich irgendwie total absurd, dass das äh überhaupt so äh gemacht wird. Es gibt ja auch,
in diesem Feld, die das nicht so tun, sondern die dann die Videos von der Cloud ablegen, aber verschlüsselt ablegen,
sollte man dann vielleicht mal drauf achten, wenn man sich äh für so eine Technologie entscheidet im eigenen Heim, aber ringt hier zumindest überhaupt gar keine Probleme damit zu haben. Das ist eben nicht nur unverschlüsselt zu tun, sondern dann eben auch das unverschlüsselte weiterzugeben, wenn da mal jemand nach.
Fragt. Ist auch so eine Art Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ja und ich also ich habe mir auch mal vor ein paar Jahren so was mit einem gebaut mhm.
Und ich bin muss echt sagen, ich bin immer also mit mit Videokameras, mit IP musst du wirklich vorsichtig sein. Wir haben ich habe mir da auch mal den Spaß gemacht, einfach.
Da kriegst du echt also du kriegst da hartwaremäßig, echt. Geile Dinger für 30 Euro auf Amazon, ne? Das ist eine Kamera, die hat einen Drehkopf, die kannst du drehen, also.
Und einen Lautsprecher.
Und am und dann gibt's eine App dazu, ja, dann machst du, gehst du auf diese Kamera ähm über die Cloud natürlich, kriegst dann den Livestream von der Kamera und kannst die nach rechts und links drehen, kannst da oben unten drücken, kannst Push-to-Talk machen, irgendetwas sagen.
Und äh die werden primär benutzt zur äh.
Ähm soll ja vorsichtig sein, was ich sage, aber wenn wenn man darauf Zugriff hätte auf dieses System, ja, was äh.
Was was vielleicht da da liegen könnte, dass diese Kameras im Auslieferungszustand
das Kennwort acht acht acht haben, ja? Also wenn jetzt jemand käme und würde sich mal äh über die Benutzungsgruppe äh dieser Kamera informieren, die werden relativ viel genutzt, werden bei irgendwelchen Rentnern in die Wohnung gestellt
damit ähm mutmaßlich, damit dann die ähm Kinder,
gucken können, ob die ob die ordnungsgemäß auf dem Sofa sitzen und Fernsehen gucken. Und äh natürlich auch teilweise zur Überwachung von anderen Räumen, aber,
Also die Kamera tatsächlich war super, aber wenn du ich habe mir nur einmal kurz angeschaut, wie dieses Backend aussieht und ähm
Das äh möchte man eigentlich nicht. Und ich glaube, man möchte das weder von irgendwelchen äh mit irgendwelchen kaputten China-Clouds am anderen Ende noch mit irgendwie Amazon am anderen Ende. Also eine,
Nee. Will man nicht.
Kameras sind auch oft selber einfach so für technisch ein großes äh Problem, wenn man sich da
nochmal in YouTube ein bisschen einlesen will. Es gibt ja noch diese geilen Kids wahrscheinlich auch. So Scammer, Payback und solche äh Kanäle, Leute, die sich einen Spaß draus machen,
so äh primär in,
Indien beheimatete Scammerbanden, ja, die versuchen irgendwelche Leute äh reinzulegen mit irgendwelchen Windows-Support Calls und so weiter, die dann Geld überweisen müssen und dann
äh sozusagen deren Kontodaten dann live mitgeschnitten und komplett äh beraubt und dann gibt's halt so so geile Anti-Scammer äh,
Truppen muss man schon fast sagen, also so Leute, die sich einen Spaß äh draus machen oder schon auch ein Business draus machen, die dann nicht nur ausfindig zu machen, sondern auch deren Callcenter dann in Indien,
sozusagen zu ermitteln und hacken sich dann in deren Netze rein, in,
die Videokameras, die da in diesen Räumen installiert sind und beobachten sozusagen die Scammer live, während sie ein Scam durchführen
ja und konfrontieren die dann auch teilweise mit so, weil sie die wirklich in dem Moment einfach live sehen, wie sie mit ihnen äh reden und die dann alle irgendwie äh zur Panik bringen, ist sehr unterhaltsam. Also
generell ist so Internet of Things, ja wir haben das glaube ich gar nicht so oft das Thema hier wirklich.
In den Fokus genommen, aber was was ja so alle etwas Computerliteraten schon immer Bauchschmerzen bereitet hat bei dieser ganzen kleinen Geräte, die komplexe Dinge im Heimnetz tun, ist einfach da,
ist halt einfach was so den Preis äh betrifft, dementsprechend wenig wird er auf Security geachtet und das sind halt einfach alle Tore ins eigene Heimnetz und das kann äh,
Kann böse enden und endet leider auch oft böse.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist das völlig unverantwortlich, was äh Ring da macht und das geht so gar nicht und auch was die Polizei da macht, dass sie das einfach ohne richterlichen Beschluss äh einfach so ermitteln,
Ja, aber da sieht man mal das Risiko, was in solchen Technologien äh drinsteckt und wenn er also wirklich so eine Kamera für euren Eingang haben wollt, dann entscheidet euch für ein System, was definitiv.
Wenn überhaupt in der Cloud was speichert's dann auch nur äh verschlüsselt tut.
Ja oder äh genau oder baut baut es euch selber.
Äh so schwer ist es nämlich nicht, aber dann irgendwann denkt man sich, ja was soll der ganze Quatsch eigentlich, wenn will ich denn da überwachen eigentlich? Ähm.
Vielleicht einfach an eine andere Tür. An anderen Türen finde ich die witzig, an meiner eigenen irgendwie nicht.
Wie könnte man denn noch überwachen?
Chatkontrolle könnte man noch überwachen, ja? Das wäre ähm Chatkontrolle bleibt Thema,
Heute haben wir ein bisschen über Vollzeitenspeicherung gesprochen, aber keine Sorge, Chatkontrolle kommt wieder. Nur weil äh einfach so in der Liste derer, die sich dagegen äh ausgesprochen haben,
Äh der EU der UN UN Menschenrechtsrechtskommissar.
Von den EU Plänen zur verdachtslosen Durchsuchung aller privaten Nachrichten und Fotos ab und bezweifelt ihre Vereinbarkeit,
mit den Menschenrechten. Das ist also das Büro des Kommissars für Menschenrechte.
OHCHR, der sagt, bei einer Allgemeindurchsuchung der Kommunikation lassen sich häufige Fehler nicht vermeiden. Recht hat der gute Mann. Selbst, wenn die Trefferquote hoch ist, so dass zahlreiche unschuldige Personen davon betroffen sind.
In Anbetracht dessen dürfte die wahllose Überwachung die freie Meinungsäußerung und die Versammlungsfreiheit,
erheblich einschränken, sodass die Menschen die Art und Weise ihrer Kommunikation und Interaktion mit anderen einschränken und zur Selbstzensur greifen.
Hat er Recht.
Hören. Nein, er ist ja nur der hohe Kommissar für Menschenrechte der UN. Was soll man auf so jemanden hören? Deswegen hat der Bundesrat sich geäußert. Den interessiert ja auch keiner.
Äh und die sagen, dass die gesamte internetbasierte Kommunikation überwacht werden müsste von den äh bei einer Aufdeckungsanordnung.
Dabei gegebenenfalls auch Kenntnisse von Inhalten erhalten werden, die dem höchstpersönlichen Lebensbereich zuzuordnen sind, korrekt.
Enthalten sein könne zudem Kommunikation mit besonders geschützten Gesprächspartner sowie Berufsgeheimnisträgerin wie Anwältinnen, Ärztinnen, Journalistinnen und Parlamentarierinnen
Das ist sehr elegant, dass da noch mal reinzubringen, weil das was der Bundesrat sagt, liest ja eigentlich dann nur der Bundestag. Und wenn wir dann nochmal die Parlamentarierin, sagt er, ey Leute, das geht auch uns was an hier, ne? Äh der Bündnis, der Bundesrat bittet
äh die Bundesregierung daher sich bei den Teils der Ausgestaltung der Verordnung dafür einzusetzen, dass deren,
Eingriffe und nutzen insbesondere für junge Menschen bestmöglich austariert werden.
Außerdem und das finde ich sehr viel wichtiger, soll mal dafür gesorgt werden, dass zur Bekämpfung von sexuellem Missbrauch effektiver und zielgerichtete Maßnahmen geschaffen werden und zugleich das Recht auf Vertraulichkeit der privaten Chemikeration
äh auch beibehalten wird
Ja, das ist richtig. Ähm wir haben jetzt alle, ne, wir haben vom Kinderschutzbund über den äh Kronenkommissar für Menschenrechte an äh,
der heißt Türk, der ist aber nicht sondern nicht Andreas Türk, ne? Wenn wenn.
Wenn nicht, wäre es ja auch egal. Vielleicht würden Sie auf den hören, den kennen die wahrscheinlich wenigstens. Na ja und dann ähm.
Es es haben jetzt alle gesagt, ne? Es kann auch nachher keiner mehr sein, das wussten wir nicht.
Finde ich ja das das finde ich ja das das Oberspannende.
Jetzt alle gesagt, jetzt müssen wir noch demonstrieren und dagegen äh gegen ähm,
Widerspruch einlegen und denen das alles doch 1hundertmal sagen und das interessiert die einfach nicht. Das ist das ist das Faszinierende.
Widerstand ist ja immer.
Widerstand musste 20 Jahre lang leisten und wenn dann vom vom fünften höchsten Gericht recht bekommen hast, dann sagen die, ja, wir werden das Urteil. Wir wir verstehen das Urteil als Arbeitsauftrag. Äh und machen weiter.
Genau, wir haben unsere Widersprechanlage eingeschaltet.
Dann haben wir ähm,
Pegasus Untersuchungsausschuss läuft auch super. Ja die Kommission wird eingeladen und sagt, hör mal Leute, wir haben hier den Untersuchungsausschuss, weil von euch Leute gehackt wurden und dann sagen die, ja, wir wollen aber nicht sagen, wer? Okay.
Dann äh ist die äh der Pegasus Untersuchungsausschuss äh nach Warschau gereist, um sich da mal äh mit mit den mit der polnischen Regierung auseinanderzusetzen.
Der hat die polnische Regierung hat sich geweigert, die Mitglieder des äh EU-Pegasus-Untersuchungsausschusses zu treffen.
Ja, die hätten gerne äh paar Akteurinnen befragt, äh wollten mit lokalen Politikerinnen und Vertreterinnen des obersten Gerichtshofes und Betroffenen der Spionage reden. Polnische Regierung sagt, nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Auch geil.
Äh wurde äh Ufer gehackt von irgendeinem Teenager, der äh der Zugriff auf alle Systeme hatte und Uwe musste musste den Laden ausschalten dann.
Und offensichtlich ist der Zugriff gelungen über äh also er hat irgendwie durch Social Engineering einen Mitarbeiter davon überzeugen können ihm doch sein Passwort zu geben.
Er hat funktioniert.
Das war jetzt mhm.
Ja, Ende der Geschichte. So, keine zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung für kritische Mitarbeiterzugänge. Ja, haste nicht anders verdient, Uber, ne? Also, ich meine, Uber ist eh äh.
Problematisch.
Sehr problematisch. Aber ja, sagen wir ist halt offenbar irgendein Teenager, der sich jetzt damit brüstet und sich für den größten Hacker hält. Ähm,
gewissermaßen muss man hier einfach sagen, also das das also so was immer zweiseitig betrachten. Das ist das ist ein,
irgendeinem Teenager gelingt einen Mitarbeiter darüber davon zu überzeugen, dass er das Passwort bekommt. Da ist zu kritisieren,
Tatsächlich die IT Security Policy von Uber.
Man sich offenbar als Mitarbeiter dort einloggen kann mit nur einem Passwort und ohne zweiten Faktor, wenn ich das jetzt so lese, ne, dass das dann eine 18-jähriger schafft, äh es spricht nicht unbedingt für den 18-jährigen, sondern gegen Uber, ne.
Auch 18 Jahre mittlerweile, ich meine das ist natürlich für Journalisten, wenn du jetzt 32 gewesen wäre, steht es wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal drin, wie alt er ist. So, 18 wird so allgemein als noch besonders jung angesehen, aber ich glaube,
Heutzutage muss man so ab 12 vielleicht die Ohren aufmachen.
Ja
Das ist ja schon Senior.
Ja vor allem vor allem der hatte der ist ja dann offensichtlich durch einen Stimmbruch und dann kann er auch am Telefon den davon überzeugen äh ihm das Passwort zu geben ja also genau 12-jähriger wäre beeindruckender gewesen.
Na ja ähm.
Habe ich aber nur ein bisschen als Einleitung genommen für diese Twitter-Diskussion. Der Matsch hatte da jetzt nochmal seinen äh hat er jetzt seinen Vortrag gehalten vom Parlament, äh weil es da ja eine Untersuchung zu gab und ja.
Ich habe mich ja ein bisschen gewundert, warum er damit an die Öffentlichkeit geht.
Kannst du noch mal kurz den Kontext nochmal aufmachen.
Ja, bin ich ja gerade dabei. Das ist derjenige, der sich, äh der quasi gesagt, der IT-Sicherheitschef bei Twitter war und sich dann da unter unklaren Bedingungen gegangen ist. Also der wurde gefeuert,
und äh sich dann jetzt an die Öffentlichkeit gewendet hat, ein paar Monate später oder ein Jahr später und sagte, hier die Zustände, die ich da vorgefunden habe, sind,
nicht tolerabel, ja und hat dann jetzt also relativ viele Dinge gesagt, die also tatsächlich auf schlechte IT-Sicherheit bei Twitter hinweisen, insbesondere auch was da Leute für Zugänge und Zugriffe alles hatten.
Erzählte dann, er hätte in der Woche, in der er vor Twit von Twitter gefeuert wurde, hätte er erfahren, dass eine Agent des chinesischen Ministeriums für Staatssicherheit bei Twitter,
auf der Gehaltsliste gestanden habe, ja? Weiß nicht, was danach jetzt äh äh könnte also nicht sagen, ob der immer noch dort arbeitet, ja? Ähm.
Und das ist aber halt deshalb ein Problem, weil so viele Twitter-Mitarbeiterinnen eben auch so weitreichende Zugänge auf dieses System haben,
Man hat ja auch immer wieder Geschichten gehört, dass irgendwie.
Wenn dann wenn dann irgendwie mal wieder Elon Musk Account übernommen wurde, dass das dass das eigentlich Social Engineering bei irgendein Twittermitarbeiter war bei diesen Orbit-Sachen, wo von irgendwelchen YouTubern ähm.
Dinge übernommen wurden, was ja auch eher so DM Scaming mit irgendwelchen Twitter-Mitarbeitern und so weiter. Ähm.
Also das das scheint schon so zu stimmen. Der Hintergrund warum ich mich gefragt habe, warum macht der das überhaupt, ja? Scheint aber eben auch zu sein, dass das bei Twitter ja,
einige Änderungen in der äh in dem Management gab. Er war quasi noch von dem Jack Dorsey, da da reingeholt worden.
Bei der Jack Dorsty sagte okay, wenn der Laden hier verkauft werden soll, dann muss da die IT-Sicherheit mit einem eisernen Besen ordentlich gemacht werden. Ich weiß, dass die nicht gut ist. Dann hatten die aber gleichzeitig dieses,
FCC äh Problem, dass sie wegen schlechter IT-Sicherheit sogar schon Probleme hatten und der Matsch wollte darüber den Aufsichtsrat informieren und hat gesagt, hier muss unbedingt etwas passieren. Das hat er aber getan,
Quasi, obwohl das Executive Management das nicht wollte und dafür haben sie ihn dann halt gefeuert. Ja?
So ungefähr die Kurzgeschichte. Also der hat der muss jetzt quasi auch an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, damit nicht die gleichen Leute, die ihnen daran gehindert haben, die IT-Sicherheit zu verbessern dann, wenn alles zusammenbricht, sagen ja, der war das, der hat das alles so schlecht gemacht, ne? Insofern
sah er sich quasi auch zur Rettung seines eigenen Allerwertesten wahrscheinlich gezwungen,
hier mal äh die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren. Elon Musk profitiert natürlich trotzdem davon, aber ähm äh das ist jetzt äh nicht,
der Grund des Matschlers geteilt hat. Das hätte ich ihm auch nicht unterstellt. Es ist nur äh natürlich
interessant, weil Elon Musk sich diese News natürlich jetzt vor äh vor den Karren spannt und sagt, das Twitter ist alles voll mit Bots und
unsicher, insofern möchte ich das nicht haben.
Der wird nachher gezwungen, das zu kaufen, ne.
Was ich glaube, ist ein bisschen unerheblich, aber das macht so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, dass er äh sich da nicht so ohne Weiteres äh rausziehen kann. Er hat sich halt
rechtlich
und die Sache wird halt jetzt da wir erwähnt in in Delleware verhandelt, das ist extrem unternehmensfreundlich, da äh wird da nicht so leicht davon kommen. Vielleicht,
legen Sie am Schluss nochmal irgendwie einen roten Teppich aus, äh dass er dann in irgendeiner Form Gracefully äh nicht ganz so viel Schaden da davonkommt und alle so ihren Schnitt machen. Äh so nach dem Motto
Du musst es jetzt nicht kaufen, aber du musst uns die Kohle geben und äh gib uns die Hälfte, dann passt das schon, dass wir halt irgend so einen Vergleich machen. Also das,
ich mir schon vorstellen, aber wie das dann.
Derzeit höchstens die Hälfte der Strafe. Es gibt ja schon eine Strafe für den äh für den für den also die ist doch vertraglich da drin, oder? So und so viele Milliarden oder.
Ja genau, also ich meine die die na
Strafe ja, aber vor allem ist er ja gezwungen, das Angebot, was er gemacht hat, was er angenommen wurde, auch zu bezahlen und der Twitterkurs ist halt niedriger.
So und wenn sie dann halt sagen, na ja, okay gut du willst es, also sie ist nicht kaufen, dann behalten wir den Scheiß halt auch, aber er muss sonst irgendwie
ne dann dann dann gibt's uns die Hälfte und das verteilen wir als Dividenda unter den äh Aktionären da sind auch alle glücklich.
Kohle gekriegt, weißt du? So muss er
was weiß ich, 20 Milliarden, aber hinblättern hat dann den Stress nicht mit Twitter. Hätte sonst noch mehr bezahlt, was weniger wert ist und äh damit ist allen gedient. So was kann ich mir vorstellen, aber die ziehen die halt jetzt auf jeden Fall erst mal vor den
und dann ja wird sich zeigen, was dabei rauskommt, aber so richtig viel Hoffnung äh würde ich mir an seiner Stelle da nicht machen.
Hat sich nicht besonders klug verhalten. Zwar eigentlich von Anfang an eine Scheißidee. Also so was,
willst du dir den Stiefel noch anziehen? Als ob du bist du nicht ausgelastet oder was? Meine,
der macht ja nicht gerade so den Eindruck, als hätte er zu wenig zu tun oder so. Ist ja nicht, dass er jetzt so in Rente gegangen wäre und dann so, oh ja, schon lange kein Unternehmen mehr geführt.
Mann, Mann, Mann, der hat irgendwie zwei zwei riesen Unternehmen an der Backe, die irgendwie jedes einzelne genug Arbeit bedeutet, aber ich weiß auch noch nicht, was diese Leute treibt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der sich noch viel mit seinen Unternehmen auseinandersetzt.
Das tut, das tut er, das tut er, das tut er.
Setzt sich den größtenteils mit irgendwie DMT auseinander.
Was weiß ich, womit er sich bestäubt, aber er ist man kann ihm jetzt nicht vorwerfen, dass er von dem, was sein Unternehmen tun, keine Ahnung hätte,
Kann man wirklich nicht.
Was kann man also man kann ihm sicherlich einiges vorwerfen, aber das bestimmt nicht. Glaube nicht, dass es so viele CEOs gibt, die du so im Detail genau wissen, was was ihr laden eigentlich wirklich tut.
Vielleicht hat er ist mir auch egal. Wir haben wir haben das glaube ich abschließend diskutiert, der wird Twitter am Ende nicht kaufen. Vielleicht die dir wird äh.
Er wird es nicht kaufen. Er wird er wird maximal 50 Prozent der Strafe zahlen müssen und der dann lache ich Helmisch und sage du Vollidiot aber der wird das ich kann ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass das der gezwungen wird etwas zu kaufen, was er nicht haben will. Es geht jetzt nur noch um die Strafe.
Und die wird halt empfindlich sein, ja.
Die Twitteraktionäre, die davon äh profitieren sollen erstmal mit der Ukraine spenden oder so.
Bestimmt.
Sind wir durch, oder?
Ich glaube, wir sind durch und äh ja, nächste Woche gibt's wieder E-Rezept. Es ist also wirklich Tipp, als diese Vorratsdatenspeicherungskram kam ja echt.
Geht schon wieder essen vorne los.
Du du denkst halt ja irgendwann, also das ist ja auch noch.
Weiß nicht, wie viele Urteile ich dazu jetzt schon verlesen habe, ne? Und es zeigt halt aber auch, ne, das sollte ja allen auch eine,
ja Mut machen, ne? Wenn man wenn man lange genug an einem Thema dran bleibt, dass dass man dann doch noch irgendwie gegen mehrere Urteile, also so ein Verfassungsgerichtsurteil ist echt nicht das Ende aller Tage.
Tja, wir sollten mal Phil Connors fragen, wie man da rauskommen kann.
Ja so ist es. Alles klar.
Das war's für heute und dann hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bis bald.